Gleich wollen wir sprechen über den internationalen Top-Fußball in Europa, im Fußball der Männer. Vorher habe ich aber noch eine wichtige Mitteilung an euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Denn unsere Bankverbindung wird sich ändern, irgendwann ab dem 19. März. Das ist extrem ätzend für uns, ist auch nicht unsere Entscheidung, denn wir werden damit sicherlich Daueraufträge verlieren von Leuten von euch, die einen Dauerauftrag abgeschlossen haben. Deswegen bitte ich euch sehr, sehr herzlich, bitte geht auf rasenfunk.de und im Menü rechts oben, da könnt ihr euch registrieren für den Rasenfunk-Supporters Club. Das bedeutet erst mal nur, dass wir eine E-Mail-Adresse von euch bekommen und ihr auf dem Mail-Verteiler aller Rasenfunk-SupporterInnen landet. Keine Angst, gibt's kein Spam. Ein bis zwei Mails pro Jahr ist aktuell so der Schnitt. Und eben jetzt werdet ihr irgendwann ab dem 19. März eine Mail erhalten mit der neuen Bankverbindung. Und dann haben wir ein relativ enges Zeitfenster, in dem ihr dann bitte eure Daueraufträge ändert. Und dann hoffen wir, dass wir über diese Umstellung ganz gut hinwegkommen. Wir hatten das ja schon mal, als wir die GmbH gegründet haben, neue Bankverbindungen, da sind uns so 15 bis 20 Prozent des Supports ist uns da verloren gegangen. Das hat wehgetan. Deswegen, bitte registriert euch und bitte habt's auf dem Schirm. Ab 19. März wird sich das ändern. Jetzt geht's aber los mit der regulären Folge. Wir sprechen mit Daniel Zander, Uli Hebel, Alex Treuker und Mallorca. Abfahrt. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Die Herren, schön, dass ihr da seid. Hi. Es wird mir zugenehmigt. Hier sind echte Podcast-Profis am Tag. Wir müssen gleich reingehen. Alex, es wird jetzt sein Thema, aber es wird unser aller Thema. War das gestern ein Double Touch bei Atletico Madrid im Elfmeterschießen gegen Real Madrid? Ich habe es gelesen. Ich habe ausgemacht, weil ich mir gedacht habe, na gut, es wird jetzt Real Madrid irgendwann in der Verlängerung gewinnen. Das möchte ich nicht sehen. Grüße an Nils, es tut mir leid, aber ich habe es zu oft gesehen und habe es dann beim Zähneputzen im Kickerticker gelesen. Und da stand einfach nur drin AVR-Check, Doppelberührung. Da dachte ich mir, oh je, er ist ausgerutscht. Und meine Güte, ja, das kann passieren. Und dann habe ich irgendwann später, ich gebe zu nachts, dann die Bilder dazu gesehen. Ich sehe die Berührung nicht. Alex, du bist natürlich völlig unbiased bei diesem Thema. Siehst du die Doppelberührung?
Ich bin tatsächlich deswegen unbiased, weil ich gestern das Spiel getickert habe für die Kollegen von The Zone.
Ich dachte schon für Kicker, das wäre jetzt unangenehm gewesen.
Da muss man natürlich unbiased sein als Sportjournalist. Und ich konnte es nicht erkennen. Ganz ehrlich. Also gestern ja sowieso nicht. Heute hast du auf Social Media, auf Twitter vor allem, siehst du ja Hunderte Superzeit-Loops. Ich glaube, TNT Sports hat da wirklich eine mega Slow-Mo mit Runzoom und Lupe und dies das. Und nicht mal da kann ich es erkennen. Deswegen ist es genug es zu overturnen, wäre mehr meine Frage. Also ist die Beweislast so groß, dass man etwas sieht, dass man sieht, oh, die vorherige Entscheidung war falsch. Nee, da ist der Double Touch. Ich muss den Call overturnen. Das ist für mich nicht gegeben.
Möchte da irgendjemand widersprechen? Ich sehe, Daniel schüttelt den Kopf, Uli schüttelt den Kopf, Mario.
Uli hast das Spiel überhaupt gesehen?
Nee, hab das Spiel nicht gesehen, aber hab wie Max die Szene natürlich gesehen.
Also zum einen war ich da auch wieder negativ überrascht von meiner Seherfähigkeit. Am Tag davor habe ich noch bei der Arbeit gesagt, Liverpool sollte jetzt ein Tor schießen, weil sonst hält Donahue mal mindestens zwei. Und gestern habe ich bei der Verlängerung gesagt, also wenn es jetzt 1-0 bleibt vor der Verlängerung, dann bleibe ich hier sitzen und esse noch ein Eis. Ich wollte das Eis eigentlich gar nicht essen, so aus Gründen, aber dann habe ich es halt doch gegessen, weil da noch eine halbe Stunde Fußball war und dann...
Niemand hat so schwer wie du. Ich musste ein Eis essen, weil ich musste noch Fußball gucken. Leute, macht die Kerzen an.
Dann sind hier andere Personen ins Bett gegangen und habe ich gesagt, wahrscheinlich gewinnt Real eh wieder im Elfmeterschießen. Und dann ist es genauso gekommen. Und also als die zweite Zeitlupe kam und glaube ich auch der Kollege Hagemann so kurz innerlich und akustisch zusammenzuckt, meine ich auch irgendwas erahnt zu haben. Aber dann guckt man sich es nochmal an und denkt, reicht erahnen dafür? Und dann sind wir wieder... Ach, ich weiß auch nicht. Also was soll das denn? Das ist doch, das ist doch, das macht doch irgendwie den Fußball insofern nicht gerecht. Er glaubt, hat Bellingham sich da irgendwie, Bellingham meint es gleich erkannt zu haben und Waske es auch. Aber er verschafft sich dadurch ja nicht mehr ein Vorteil. Er wollte ihn ja da oben hinknallen. Im Zweifel sozusagen ist es sogar eh. Ich weiß, rein regeltechnisch darf er ihn nicht zweimal berühren, aber also.
Wobei ich da jetzt sogar gesehen habe, dass es schon Leute gibt, die die Regeln da anders auslegen und sagen man darf einen bewegenden Ball, da darf man nicht quasi schießen. Und in dem Fall wäre es mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig. Aber das sind jetzt wirklich Details. Alex, Entschuldigung, ich hab dich unterbrochen.
Ja, ich würde gerne Manuel Grefet zitieren, denn er hat manchmal ganz gerne ausführlich geäußert. Der zahlt offenbar an den Kollegen Masks. Er darf immer mehr schreiben, hat immer mehr Platz als ich. Ich will das kurz vorlesen.
Machst du bitte Punkte und so rein, denn die werden ja fehlen.
Ja, dadurch, dass er offenbar jetzt die 8 Euro an Elon Musk zahlt, hat er mehr Platz und kann besser schreiben. Kann Satzzeichen und so machen, deswegen okay. Also ich lese vor, Manuel Grefet hat sich dazu geäußert, final zu Alvarez. Ist das klar und offensichtlich genug, um das Tor nicht zu geben? Es ist eine Definitionsfrage, wie man wahr eingesetzt wissen möchte. Und es ist sogar eine Klarstellung der Spielregeln nötig, also er holt ein bisschen aus. Also Klarstellung, deswegen ist es überhaupt eine doppelte Berührung, fragt Grefet. Wenn ja, fast gleichzeitig oder doch ein minimaler Kontakt. Es fühlt sich falsch an, das Tor im Elfmeterschießen nicht zu geben. Klarstellung, Spielregeln, Doppelpunkt. Es ist verboten, den Ball durch den Schützen zweimal zu berühren, aber es ist eigentlich nur verboten, den Ball ein zweites Mal zu berühren, zu spielen, wenn der Ball im Spiel ist. Der Ball ist aber erst im Spiel, wenn er sich deutlich bewegt. Genau. Ist also womöglich ein Widerspruch, den man dann aufgrund dieses Falles vielleicht mal klarstellen muss, also seitens der FIFA, der Regelhüter. Abgesehen davon sieht es bei Alvarez eher nach einem fast gleichzeitigen Kontakt aus. Für Grefe eine harte und umstrittene Entscheidung. Das war im Elfmeterschießen mit so viel Tragweite. Vielleicht sollten sich FIFA und UEFA das klarstellen auch für die Zukunft. Also man ließ glaube ich heraus, dass es für ihn dann vielleicht doch nicht so klar und offensichtlich war, dass man dieses Tor annullieren sollte, ne?
Aber davon abgesehen, Alex, also da drüber kann man sich jetzt sehr ärgern. Ich finde es auch schwierig, wenn auf dieser Bühne so eine Unklarheit besteht. Also da muss es eindeutig sein oder es muss aufgeklärt werden von der UEFA, aber von denen werden wir jetzt gar nichts hören. Also das ist so wie in vielen anderen Ligen auch, was Schiedsrichter angeht, da hört man im Zweifel erstmal gar nichts. Aber darüber hinaus gab es ja vorher auch noch ein Spiel und Atletico hätte ja auch die Möglichkeit gehabt es in 120 Minuten gegen Real zu regeln. Was ist da los, dass Atletico auf europäischer Bühne gegen Real Madrid, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange man nicht mehr so gewonnen hat, dass man weitergekommen ist.
Also ich glaube erstmal, um die Statistik rauszukramen, seit 2014 haben sie fünfmal auf europäischer Bühne gegen Real Madrid verloren. Ich glaube sechsmal insgesamt international, also sobald sie international auf die treffen, scheiden sie aus auf die verschiedensten dramatischen Art und Weise. Champions League Finale, Kopfball Tor Ramos in der Nachspielzeit, in der Verlängerung dann verloren, im Elfmeterschießen in Mailand haben sie schon Champions League Finale verloren, jetzt eben wieder im Elfmeterschießen gegen Real Madrid. Also es ist einfach, ja, Athletikos Kryptonit der Stadtnachbar und vor allem die dramatische Art und Weise. Elfmeter schießen hier, Kopfball in der Nachspielzeit da und jetzt eben wieder Elfmeterschießen und vor allem aufgrund dieses vermeintlichen Double-Touches oder eben nicht. Das ist schon auch irgendwie die Story, dass Athletiko so dermaßen viel Unglück, Pech hat, an sich selbst scheitert, an vielleicht dem Schiri scheitert, an dem Elfmeterpunkt, dem Rasen scheitert. Das ist schon auch eine große Story, die man auch nicht immer logisch erklären kann. Gehört auch dazu. Also irgendwie hat der Athletiko gegen diesen Gegner sehr, sehr viel Pech einfach.
Wobei ja auch Vinicius den Elfmeter verschießt. Also im Gesamtkontext sieht das so aus, als ob Athletiko da einfach eine Serie hat, die sich immer weiter fortsetzt. Und das ist dann glaube ich auch so. Aber im Spiel selber hat Athletiko ja auch Glück. Also Vinicius verschießt den Elfmeter. Klar, man hat die eine Chance in der 88. Muss er rüberlegen, sag ich jetzt einfach mal hier als Sofartrainer. Aber gut, ist halt vielleicht auch ein bisschen einfacher, das hier zu machen und nicht im Stadion, wenn man diesen Beikontakt hat im gegnerischen Strafraum. Aber Real hatte ja dann eigentlich ganz gute Möglichkeiten, hat auch auf den frühen Rückstand reagiert. Also wie wird es das dann sportlich sehen, jetzt mal jenseits von Pech und Glück?
Also grundsätzlich ein Tor in der ersten Minute nach 27 Sekunden ist der optimale Start, der dir nur so gelingen kann. Und was dann auffällig war, dass sie in den nächsten, sagen wir mal 20 Minuten nur hinten drin standen, Real den Ball überließen und auf Konter- und Umschaltmöglichkeiten setzen. Und da könnte man schon argumentieren, ey wenn du sie direkt nach einer Minute erwischt, den Gegner, dann bleib doch dran mit deinem Fans im Rücken. Mach doch weiter Druck, geh weiter drauf, versuch Real direkt den nächsten Tiefschlag zu geben. Aber sie ziehen sich zurück und ihr und das haben sie quasi das ganze Spiel über gemacht, dass sie wirklich abwarten, dass sie tief stehen im Block. Real Madrid hat dann keinerlei Ideen, hat eine sehr langsame Ball-Zirkulation, viel Ballbesitz natürlich, aber eben wurde auch kaum gefährlich und Atletico war zufrieden mit diesem Spielstil, dass man sagt, wir stehen tief, wir haben das 1-0, wir sind auf Kurs, Verlängerung, Elfmeterschießen, also wir haben es egalisiert und jetzt versuchen wir sie im Konter im Umschaltspiel irgendwie noch mal zu erwischen und das hat ja eigentlich sogar ganz gut geklappt. Also sie waren die gefährlichere Fußballmannschaft vor allem in der ersten Halbzeit, hatten da drei Abschlüsse, die Coutar hielt. Ich kann mich an keine große Parade von Oblak erinnern, zumindest der ersten Halbzeit, also eigentlich machten sie für mich zu wenig aufgrund dieses 1-0s in der ersten Minute, aber gleichzeitig hat es ja trotzdem so funktioniert, dass sie die gefährlichere Mannschaft waren, aber irgendwie den Hebel haben sie nie umgesetzt. Und wenn du dann natürlich im Elfmeterschießen ausscheidest, kannst du dich schon fragen lassen, warum bist du nie wirklich entschlossen aufs zweite Tor, aufs Siegtor gegangen, sondern hast es aus Elfmeterschießen ankommen lassen, An- und Abführung. Das darf man Simeone schon mal fragen, denn wie gesagt, ich glaube, wenn sie mehr Druck machen, klar, dann lässt du hinten mehr Räume zu für Mbappé, Vinicius. Die hatten keine Räume, mit der einen Ausnahme der Elfmeterszene. Das war das einzige Mal, dass Mbappé mal Raum hat, zwei Gegner stehen lässt, tolles Dribbling macht, tief geht, gefault wird. Ansonsten gab es nie Räume. Das heißt, sie haben real-matri-nullified, wenn man so möchte, mit der Taktik. Also es hat funktioniert. Aber gleichzeitig kannst du schon argumentieren, ey, geh doch irgendwie aufs zweite Tor, nimm ein bisschen mehr Risiko, lauft früher mal an, geht früher drauf, versucht mehr Ballbesitz zu haben. Vielleicht könnt ihr real Madrid auch nach 90 oder 120 Minuten schlagen und seid gar nicht vom Elfmeterschießen abhängig. Also das sind so die, finde ich, sportlich-taktischen Geschichten dieses Spiels für mich.
Ja, interessant. In den letzten fünf Spielen in la Liga hat man viermal eins zu eins gespielt und einmal gewonnen gegen real. Und man sagt ja immer Defens-Wins-Championships, aber halt nur gegen Teams, die das nicht extrem gewohnt sind, gegen tiefstehende Gegner zu spielen. Da funktioniert das dann eben offenbar auf die lange Sicht dann doch nicht. Aber da steckt auch noch eine größere Diskussion hinter, auch mit anderen Teilnehmern, also anderen Vereinen, über die man da reden könnte, als nur über Atletico. Also das war das Ausscheiden von Atletico. Lasst mal in die Niederlande gehen. Feyenoord hat ja durchaus ein bisschen für Furore gesorgt in der Champions League. Das hörte aber dann irgendwann sehr schnell auf. Und jetzt hat man einen neuen Trainer, Daniel.
Genau, so ist es. Vor gut drei Wochen schon übernahm Robin van Persie den Club. Und es ist ja eine absolute Vereinslegende und Vereinsikone. Dort lag ein Spieler gewesen und war in den letzten Jahren dort auch Jugendtrainer in verschiedenen Jugendabteilungen, U18, U19, zweite Mannschaft. Und der soll jetzt ein bisschen Ruhe reinbringen. Aber da es Feyenoord ist und Feyenoord aktuell nicht zur Ruhe kommen kann, aus irgendwelchen physikalischen Gründen, ist immer noch Unruhe da. Zur Erinnerung, genau wir hatten eine Saison zu vergessen bei Feyenoord. Aktuell sind sie auf Platz fünf. Sie sind aus dem Pokal raus. Sie sind jetzt auch gegen Inter aus der CL geflogen und haben im Laufe der Saison auch breiten Risiken entlassen und hatten jetzt die Hoffnung oder haben die Hoffnung, mit Van Persen dauerhafte Lösungen und Vereinssekunde zu haben, um auch mal auf der Position Ruhe reinzubringen. Aber wie schon gesagt, Ruhe ist so ein Schichtpunkt bei Feyenoord, was aktuell schwer zu erreichen ist. Und mit dem neuen Trainer kamen auch gleich Druck und neue Fragen und auch Kritik. Zum einen muss man sagen, dass Van Persie ja in der Saison bei Herrn Fehn eigentlich angestellt war und ist dann mitten in der Saison jetzt gewechselt von Herrn Fehn zu Feyenoord. Und das fand auch Herr Fehn nicht ganz so doll. Und da hat auch der Generale Direktor der Hahn gesagt, auch öffentlich, na ja, das Zeitpunkt ist schon ungünstig für uns. Wir hätten Robin van Persie gerne bis zum Ende der Saison gehalten. Haben das öffentlich so formuliert. Das heißt, er hat sich zumindest Herrn Fehn keine Freunde gemacht. Immerhin bekommt der Club eine abblutete Summe. Wie hoch die ist, wird nicht gesagt, aber niedrig wird sie jetzt glaube ich nicht sein. Und das ist so ein bisschen die Entschädigung. Und die eigentliche Frage, die man sich dann auch stellen muss, warum holt Fehn und eigentlich jetzt mitten in der Saison Robin van Persie in einer Saison zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo ja sofort Druck drauf ist. Fehnort muss auf Platz drei eigentlich landen in der Liga, um noch die Qualifikation für die Champions League zu erreichen. Die ersten beiden Plätze, da wäre man sicher dabei, aber die sind eigentlich unerreichbar für Fehnort. Da sind Ajax und PSV drauf. Also Fehnort hat jetzt elf Punkt Rückstand auf Eindhoven und noch mehr auf Ajax. Das wird nichts mehr in dieser Saison. Und auch Platz drei ist eigentlich nicht gesagt, dass Fehnort das relativ einfach erreichen kann. Da ist jetzt Utrecht drauf, die haben auch schon fünf Punkte Vorsprung auf Fehnort. Und Utrecht hatte jetzt zuletzt auch einen Durchhänger, aber die haben sich wieder gefangen. Weil ich traue Utrecht auch zu, Platz drei zu landen am Ende der Saison. Und auch Twente, die auch noch vor Fehnort stehen, machen eine sehr gute Saison. Das heißt, Van Persie ist gleich unter Druck. Und zwischen Van Persie und Priskel war Pascal Bosrath als Interimstrainer in der Seitenlinie bei Fehnort. Und da ist schon die Frage, warum hat der eigentlich nicht die Saison zu Ende trainiert? Weil der ja sagen können, okay, er hat es gut gemacht. Er hat in der Liga gleich gegen Almere gewonnen. Er kam gegen Milan weiter in der Champions League. Also die reinen Ergebnisse sprechen ja für Bosrath. Und da ist natürlich schon die Frage, wäre es nicht sinnvoller gewesen, Van Persie vielleicht erst am Ende der Saison zu holen, wo er dann auch zur neuen Saison zu holen, wo er eine Transferperiode hat, wo er eine Vorbereitungszeit hat, wo er seine Spielidee implementieren kann. Und da ist, ich glaube, ein Grund dazu, bei Bosrath die fehlende UEFA Pro-Lizenz. Also er hätte sowieso nur vier Wochen ohne Lizenz trainieren dürfen in der Eredivisie. Und ab dann hätten Punkt- und erst Geldstrafen und dann Punktstrafen gedroht. Und meine Vermutung ist, dass Feyenoord dieses Risiko nicht eingehen wollte. Also ich glaube, kringe Geldstrafen hätte man als Verein noch in Kauf genommen. Aber wenn es dann um Punktstrafen geht, die generell blöd sind. Aber gerade in der Situation, wenn Feyenoord der Dritte werden muss, wenn dann noch Punktabzug drohen, das würde glaube ich die Mission Platz 3 noch mal erheblich erschweren. Und ich denke, man wollte einfach da zumindest auch rechtlich auf sicheren Seiten sein. Da hat sich dann dafür entschieden, Van Persie jetzt zu holen, auch gegen eine Ablösesumme. Und auch mit dem Risiko, dass ja die Saison nicht auf Platz 3 abfließt, was dann wieder einen größeren Umbruch münden würde im Ende zu neun Saison. Aber immerhin würde man so rechtlich auf sicheren Seiten stehen. Insofern, ja.
Und also das wird ja sehr wahrscheinlich der Grund sein. Gleichzeitig glaubt man ja an Van Persie, der bisher auch nur bei Feyenoord Trainer war, also im Jugendbereich und dann später, ja doch im Jugendbereich, dann zu Herrenwehen gewechselt ist und jetzt eben quasi zurückkommt. Also man muss ihm ja vertrauen und darauf vertrauen, dass er ein guter Trainer ist und es schafft eben auch in dieser Situation eine Verbesserung herbeizuführen. Und dann musst du ihn eigentlich früh holen. Wenn du an ihn glaubst, dann kannst du ihn auch gleich holen. Dann kannst du nicht sagen, der Druck ist jetzt zu groß. Plus der Interim-Coach hat sowieso ein Verfallsdatum, also eben als Hauptcoach wegen seiner fehlenden Trainerlizenz. Aber was ist denn dein Eindruck? Ist denn Robin van Persie auch ein annähernd guter Trainer, wie er als Spieler war? Weil wir ja gerade bei ehemaligen Spielern immer diesen Bias haben. Ich meine, wir alle haben den Kopfball vor Augen, wenn wir über Robin van Persie sprechen. Das ist einfach so. Und ich schau mir ein aktuelles Bild von ihm an und denk mir so, Wahnsinn, der sieht noch so aus wie früher, nur noch viel besser. Warum sehe ich mit 41 nicht so aus? Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Aber was kann denn Robin van Persie als Trainer?
Also das ist eine sehr, sehr gute Frage. Also rein von der Statistik ist es jetzt vielleicht nicht der Trainer, den man sofort auf dem Zettel hat. Also bei Herrn Fehn hatte er neun Siege, sechs Räme und elf Unentschieden. Also eher eine leicht negativen Bilanz. Dazu gab es so schöne Spiele, wie es neun zu eins gegen PSV, als er verloren hat, wo er sich danach hingestellt hat und meinte, er sei stolz auf die Spieler. Stimmt, das war ja auch ein Fantasie, richtig. Genau, das musste ich erst mal trauen. Nach so einer Herrenklatze, und er ist ja eigentlich fast schon unvertrieben, ich bin jetzt stolz auf die Spieler, also es ist schon so, dass er jetzt nicht irgendwie die Top-Bilanzen hat, aber ich finde ihn vom Gesamtpaket, vom Spielstil einfach extrem zumindest spannend und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es bei Fehn vielleicht besser funktioniert, als bei Herrn Fehn, also er hat selbst gesagt, er will Offensivfußball, er will Unterhaltung und die hat er mit Herrn Fehn auch geliefert, also vorne viel Tor geschlossen, hinten viel kassiert, das war eigentlich nie langweilig bei Herrn Fehn. Er sagt selbst, Cardiola ist ein Vorbild und das hat er auch bei Herrn Fehn versucht umzusetzen, also Herrn Fehn ist ja jetzt eigentlich so ein Mittel, das ist ein Verein aus der Eredivisie, hat dort extrem viel Ballbesitz etabliert. Ich glaube Herrn Fehn hatte nachweislich die meisten Ballbesitzphasen in der Liga, lässt hinten auch Korspassspiel aufbauen, der Torwart wird ins Spiel integriert, ist Mitspielender Torwart, presst viel, hat hohe Ballgewinne und er hat es geschafft das mit Herrn Fehn zu implementieren, was an sich schon eine gute Leistung ist. Das Problem ist, dass er glaube ich, da zu forsch ist und zu viel möchte in meinen Augen. Also er entscheidet sich dann gerne mal im Zweifel für den Spieler, der technisch versierter ist als für den zweitkampfstarken robusten Spieler. Und das führt vor allem dazu, dass er bei Ecken und bei Freistößen sehr anfällig ist und das das Team ist sehr anfällig. Er setzt bei den Standards eigentlich fast nur auf Mannendeckung. Du hast irgendwie keinen Blocker, du hast keine rauendeckung. Und diese Kombination aus reiner Mannendeckung und zweitkampfstarken Spielern ist bei Ecken und Freistößen keine gute Kombination. Und das musste Herrn Fehn dann auch erfahren in der Liga. Also es ist vielversprechend, würde ich sagen, seine Spielidee und auch unterhaltsam. Und die Frage ist halt, ob es bei Feyenoord dann funktioniert. Also ich kann es noch nicht beurteilen. Wir hatten jetzt ein 0-0 gegen Neumirchen in der Liga. Das war eigentlich auch schon wieder so ein bisschen Tristez. Neumirchen hat sich dann hinten reingestellt und Feyenoord hat noch keine Lösung gefunden mit Ball. Und in der CL ist man jetzt rausgeflogen gegen Inter. Wobei das aber auch, glaube ich, an der individuellen Klasse von so einem Türrahmen zum Beispiel, der von 5.5. Mai lag. Also es ist doch jetzt noch nicht so, dass ich jetzt sagen konnte, nach den drei Spielen kann man da was beurteilen. Ich glaube, es wird sowieso erst spannend nächste Saison. Also Feyenoord laboriert aktuell an einer großen Versetzungsmiserie. Wilquent in Timber zum Beispiel ist wieder verletzt und da mussten sie im Winter ja Ribbons abgeben. Also der Kader ist momentan sowieso auf Kante genäht. Und auch gegen Inter musste man zwangsläufig auf sehr viele Jugendkräfte oder Sägnisten zurückgreifen. Und es wird, glaube ich, wirklich spannend, wenn nächste Saison die Verletzten zurückkehren, wenn nächste Saison neue Spieler gekauft werden, was dann Van Persie mit so einer Vorbeutungszeit macht. Und eine Sache muss ich noch kurz erzählen, weil Van Persie bei Herrn Feen das schon gemacht hat. Er ist einer der wenigen Trainer, die nicht mit einer festen Nummer eins im Tor in die Saison gegangen sind. Also in Herrn Feen hattest du Andries Knoppert und Micky van der Hardt. Und die haben sich nicht abgewechselt. Bei Freiten war es ja, glaube ich, mal so, als die beiden Töter verbrücken und weiß nicht, wer der andere war, die immer so abgewechselt haben von Spiel zu Spiel. Und Van Persie macht das wirklich abhängig vom Gegner. Und von daher schon eine Ausrichtung. Dann spielt man drei Spiele Knoppert, dann mal zwei van der Hardt. Er gab es auch schon sehr viel Kritik und Rumoren natürlich. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, was bei Feen noch passiert, wenn Bailou wieder fit ist. Bailou ist jetzt noch verletzt, der ist raus die Saison. Aktuell steht Wellenreuter im Tor. Und bin ich auch gespannt, ob er das bei Feyenoord dann kommende Saison, wenn beide wieder fit sind, auch so macht.
Einer der vielen Schalker, der dann Champions-League-Erfahrung gesammelt hat. Nicht mehr bei Schalke. Mario, du wolltest noch was?
Ja, ganz kurz, weil ich die Feyenoord tatsächlich ein paar Mal gesehen hab, auch unter Bossard und bei Bosschart, Bosskart und jetzt unter Van Persie. Also was man tatsächlich auch gegen Inter schon gesehen hat, wo ehrlicherweise schon vor Anpfiff des Hinspiels für mich klar war, wer da weiterkommt und dann hat Wellenreuther auch nach dem zweiten Spiel gesagt, es ist einfach ein kreatiellen Klassenunterschied und den hat man teilweise auch gesehen, nicht nur wegen der Verletzten, aber das was du gemeint hast, offensiv und wild war es auf jeden Fall was Van Persie angeboten hat. Also obwohl das Hinspiel durch das frühe Tor auch schon entschieden war, wurde es für mich als Kommentator auch nie langweilig, weil die draufgegangen sind wie die Verrückten, teilweise auch ein bisschen unstrukturiert im Anlaufverhalten und dann hinter sich irgendwann gesagt hat, was man ja von denen auch nicht immer, also die verwalten ja gerne dann auch mal ein 1-0-2-0, aber da hatten die dann irgendwie das Gefühl, ach so, wenn das so ist, dann überspielen wir jetzt auch eure Linien und dann ist es zu unfassbar vielen Torschancen gekommen auf beiden Seiten, wo ich auch dachte, ja, glaub, so den offensiven Matchplan hat man auf jeden Fall erkannt bei Van Persie, genau. Aber ja, wahrscheinlich sehen wir sie ja dann nächstes Jahr leider nicht in der Champions League, aber dann kann er ja da Neuaufbau betreiben.
Also man muss schon sagen, dass sich Van Persie auch nicht beöhren lässt, ob des Gegners. Also da ist egal, ob das nominale Abschlusskandidat ist oder ob das Intermeinland ist, er zieht seinen Stiefel relativ konsequent durch. Das kann in manchen Situationen gut sein, das kann manche Situationen hinten losgehen. Aber spannend wird es erst ab der nächsten Saison, wenn Van Persie da mal ein bisschen Zeit bekommt und er aus dem Vorschöpfen kann. Ja, CL, ich bin auch skeptisch. Ich glaube wirklich eher, dass Utrecht oder Enschede auf das Freilanden werden und die Chance haben werden, sich zu qualifizieren. Aber ich denke, mindestens in der Europa League dürfen wir sie dann sehen.
Also der Fair Notter Junge, er ist zurückgekehrt zu seinem Verein und lässt interessanten Fußball spielen. Mario, wenn du eh gerade mit dabei bist, dann lass uns bei interessanten Fußball verbleiben. Ich frage mich, ob wir das jetzt einfach so durchziehen werden bis zum 14. Mai oder wann auch immer dann genau, dass wir sagen, meine Güte ist das spannend an der Tabellenspitze in der Serie A. Was ist da jetzt alles wieder passiert zuletzt?
Ja, genau. Ich hab gedacht, ich bringe mal ein Positiverlebnis mit, weil man könnte natürlich auch schon wieder über Milan reden, man könnte über Juve reden, aber das wollen wir alles nicht. Wir wollen jetzt Spannung im Meisterkampf und da ist ja kaum gegeben in Europa ist Torblieben. Ich glaube in Spanien ist auch noch ein bisschen was los.
Ein bisschen spannend.
Wir haben die Konstellation, dass Inter gerade Tabellenführer ist mit 61 Punkten dahinter, Napoli mit 60 Zählern und wieder nur zwei dahinter Atalanta. Und tatsächlich, um deine Frage zu beantworten, traue ich es allen drei Teams zu, dass sie das bis Mitte, Ende Mai durchziehen, auch wenn sie ganz unterschiedliche Restprogramme haben und eigentlich die Stärken auch Kaderbreite auf die Kaderbreite bezogen, schon unterschiedlich sind, aber das gleicht sich durch das Restprogramm aus. Also wenn man jetzt mal zum Beispiel sagen würde, dass Inter einen viel breiteren Kader hat als Napoli und Napoli ist zuletzt auch so eine kleine Schwächephase hatte, viele unentschieden, unter anderem aber auch im Topspiel gegen Inter, wo sie kurz vor Schluss einen Ausgleich gemacht haben, was dann wieder sich angefühlt hat, glaube ich, wie ein Sieg, weil da hätte Inter wegziehen können, hat halt Napoli tatsächlich bis auf eine Partie gegen Milan, die man ja tatsächlich nicht mehr als Spitzenmannschaft bezeichnen kann und gegen Bologna nur noch Teams ab Platz zehn im Restprogramm und bei Inter kommt noch der Pokal dazu, wo es im Halbfinale Hin und Rückspiel an Derby geben wird gegen Milan. Wir wissen alle, Inter wird jetzt dann Anfang April zwei Spiele gegen die Bayern haben und dann danach wahrscheinlich noch die zwei Partien im Halbfinale der Champions League. Also da ist auf jeden Fall so der Belastungsfaktor relativ hoch. Bei Atalanta müsste man eigentlich meinen, dass die relativ jetzt schnell raus sein werden, weil sie ein unfassbares Restprogramm haben. Also die haben jetzt als nächstes jetzt am Wochenende Heimspiel gegen Inter. Wenn sie das gewinnen, sind sie punktgleich mit denen. Und es ist Atalanta zuzutrauen. Die haben Juwe im Allianz Stadium 4-0 weggefiedelt am vergangenen Spieltag. Das war auf jeden Fall noch mal ein Statement. Und ja, da kann ich allen nur empfehlen. Christian Bernhardt ist auch mit dabei mit Karsten Fuß. Ich bin da leider im Neckar Stadion. Max, du musst ja auch Bundesliga gucken. Ich würde aber allen, die auf Leverkusen verzichten können, empfehlen Atalanta Inter anzugucken.
Ich bin großer Freund vom Second Screen. Glaubt mir, Fußball ist die perfekte Sportart dafür. Es passiert ganz selten auf beiden Bildschirmen gleichzeitig was. Also auf jeden Fall beides gucken.
Also ich glaube, ob es ein Dreikampf bleibt, können wir Mitte April sagen, weil Atalanta, wie angesprochen, die spielen gegen Inter, dann bei der Fiorentina, zu Hause gegen Lazio, gegen Bologna, bei Milan. Das sind die nächsten Aufgaben für Gasperini und Co. Wenn es einer Mannschaft zuzutrauen ist, dann würde ich sagen, aber Atalanta, also ich würde zum Beispiel aus Napoli-Sicht eher Angst vor diesen vermeintlich kleinen Gegnern haben, die sich hinten reinstellen, weil unter Antonio Konter im Vergleich zu den anderen beiden Mannschaften, wenn man sich auch mal das Torverhältnis anguckt, defensiv gesehen sind sie alle relativ ausgeglichen, aber Atalanta und Inter haben fast 20 Tore mehr geschossen als Napoli. Also dieser, den haben wir auch, ich glaube in der Hinrunde ein, zwei Mal angesprochen, der Minimalismus den Konter praktiziert, ist eventuell fällt er denen natürlich in so einem Spiel gegen einen sehr tief stehenden Gegner irgendwann auf die Füße. Aber ja, also es ist unfassbar spannend und ich hoffe sehr, dass es genauso bleibt.
Vor allem, es sind ja drei gute Geschichten. Also bei Inter hast du halt, die haben es schon geschafft, sich an die absolute auch europäische Spitze zu spielen, ohne das aber krönen zu können und das könnte in diese Saison drin sein. Du hast da ja auch schon deinen Tipp ein bisschen mit einfließen lassen gerade. Bei Napoli haben wir die Konter-Geschichte und im Grunde, dass wir alle genau wussten, was passiert und jetzt tun sie es aber auch und es ist schön, das zu sehen. Also es ist ja genauso, wie wir es vor der Saison gesehen haben. Und Atalanta ist halt zum einen, haben sie diesen europäischen Erfolg jetzt im letzten Jahr sich geholt. Und es ist quasi der ganzen Geschichte dieses Vereins und des Umfelds, es ist einfach immer noch Wahnsinn, dass so ein Team auch mal Erfolg hat. Also weißt du, die deutschen Atalantas steigen alle ab. Und wir wissen jetzt gar nicht, ob sie irgendwie in der zweiten Liga noch weiter...
Warte, warte, warte, wer ist das deutsche Atalanta, Max? Du liebst doch immer diese Quervergleiche.
Naja, also Schalke kannst du ja da auf jeden Fall...
Schalke ist das deutsche Atalanta.
Hätte ich gesagt so. Gut, ich bin natürlich noch ein bisschen geprägt von dem Ultrafilm über Atalanta, den Mario und ich auch zusammen gesehen haben. Aber so in der Fanatik, aber auch in dem, was die Region dann vielleicht gar nicht für alle dort Lebenden, Arbeitenden und nicht Arbeitenden Bevölkerungsteile zu bieten hat. Vielleicht. Aber es muss immer schief sein, so ein Vergleich.
Aber Mario, wer ist für dich das deutsche Atalanta?
Auf die Frage war ich nicht vorbereitet.
Wer der Bremen kommt jetzt, dachte ich.
Ne, SC Freiburg vielleicht.
Oh.
Aber tatsächlich nur aufs Sportliche bezogen. Also wenn man auch diesen Quervergleich anstreben möchte, was ist, wenn jetzt Gasparini geht, steht zur Debatte, dass der U23-Trainer, gerade den Bergamo tatsächlich, da lassen die auch alle durch alle Jugendmannschaften das gleiche System spielen, das der dann übernimmt, der wiederum selber auch jetzt nicht so viele wie Julian Schuster, aber auch paar Spieler als Profi unter Gasparini gemacht hat. Das könnte irgendwie passen. So wenn sollte Gasparini sich da wirklich mit dem Pokal verabschieden und dann ein Serbettical machen, dass er nach zwei Monaten abricht, weil er merkt, dass er zu Hause es gar nicht aushält und wieder irgendwo trainieren muss. Und dann wird er Juve-Trainer und irgendwie sowas. Bei Christian Streich hält es ja tatsächlich ganz gut aus. Dortmund. Dortmund?
Naja, okay, es ist was anderes. Okay, aber es ist auf jeden Fall.
Genau, aber es ist halt schon auch so, es gibt so viele, viele Punkte, die dann irgendwie einen Fußball-Romantiker bei Atalanta auch anspringen. Jetzt hat Gasparini, ist hinter Trapattoni der Trainer mit den meisten Spielen für einen einzigen Verein. Also in der Serie A fast 340 Spiele schon. Bei Traps ein bisschen über 400 bei Juve. Marten Deron, auch so ein kleiner Unsung Hero für mich immer, der da auch ewig im Verein ist, hat ein Rekord eingestellt für einen Spieler, der die meisten Partien unter einem einzigen Trainer in Italien gespielt hat. Davor war es Name-Dropping. Sebastian Frei wäre den noch auf dem Schirm unter Cesare Brandelli.
Florian Storhüter.
Ja, genau. Also, ja, wäre wünschenswert, dass es einen Dreikampf bleibt. Und bei Napoli ist es halt tatsächlich so ein bisschen now or never, weil die werden nächstes Jahr mit Champions League unterkonten, das nicht durchziehen können. Und ich hatte vor zwei, drei Wochen das Gefühl, jetzt müssen sie abreißen lassen, weil sie tatsächlich auch der sehr dünne Kader und der rotiert ja eh ungern und dann fällt ihnen Neres aus. Und sie haben ja zur Wut der Tifosi überhaupt nichts im Winter gemacht oder fast gar nichts. Weil sie auch einfach mal gesagt haben, wir behalten das Geld für Quarterscale ja und geben es nicht großartig aus oder verteilen es über mehrere Spieler, die aber auch nur ein bisschen Ergänzung sind unter ihm. Gilmour etc. kann man da nennen. Aber ja, von daher muss es eigentlich dieses Jahr funktionieren bei Napoli. Und man hat auch bei allen dreien, um das dann vielleicht so zum Abschluss des Themas zu zu nehmen und vielleicht auch schon so ein kleiner Ausblick auf die Champions League, bei was alle drei Vereine gerade, würde ich sagen vereint ist, dass sie ein unfassbar krasses Mannschaftsgefüge haben. Also bei allen habe ich es gef- also bei Inter hast du Lautaro Martinez ist 90 Minuten draußen, ist gemeinsam mit Anatovic der erste, der beim Jubel an der Eckfahne bei allen steht. Alle freuen sich für alle, alle. Bei Napoli hast du Raspardori, der erst unzufrieden ist, dass er nicht spielen darf. Dann, dann muss er jetzt und ist auf einmal da und alle freuen sich mit ihm. Giovanni Simeone ist damit zufrieden, dass er fünf Minuten jedes Spiel mal bekommt und ist sonst auch der erste irgendwie bei jedem Torjubel, der mit reinspringt in die Traube. Atalanta ist ja so so gefestigt und zusammengewachsen in den Jahren. Also ich glaube, dass das tatsächlich und das ist immer wieder schön zu sehen, wenn man merkt, dass solche weichen Faktoren doch auch ausschlaggebend sein können für Erfolg im Fußball. Genau, ich glaube, dass bei Inter ist das eine Sache auf jeden Fall, auf die sich Vence en Compagnie und Kollegen einstellen müssen, dass dann eingeschworene Truppe mit viel Qualität auf sie zukommt.
Also in der Serie A, es bleibt spannend. Was allerdings nicht spannend ist, ist das Ende der Premier League-Tabelle. Uli, wir wollen sprechen über den FC Southampton mit Letizier, also wenn wir schon bei Name Dropping sind, Le Garde. Er hat wahrscheinlich eine Träne im Auge, weil das ist ja wirklich, wirklich düster bei Southampton. 28 Spiele festhalten, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, neun Punkte. Ist der Tasmania-Berlin-Vergleich, wie weit hergeholt ist der noch?
Heute hast du es aber wieder mit vergleichen. Die sind auf dem Weg. Es gibt noch ein Team, das war eine historische, also man muss ja immer sagen 38 Spiele. Und Derby County hat in der Saison, ich glaube 27, 28 müsste es gewesen sein, haben die neun, elf Punkte geholt insgesamt. Und ich hab tatsächlich noch mal nachgefragt bei einem Podcast, mit dem wir so eine kleine Freundschaft pflegen. Bei Derby County die reiben sich schon ein wenig die Hände, weil sie denken, die sind so mies, könnte sein, dass die uns den Rekord abnehmen.
Aber die haben doch noch zehn Spiele, um noch zwei Punkte zu machen, um den Rekord einzusteigen. Oder einen Sieg und dann hätten sie es.
Aber hast du sie mal gesehen?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Ich leider zu oft und deshalb, das heißt leider, es ist ja irgendwie auf eine Weise unterhaltsam, was die mitunter verbrechen. Also Spaß beiseite für die sehr, sehr junge Mannschaft, für den sehr, sehr jungen Kader. Da sind durchaus gute Leute mit dabei. Tut es mir echt fast leid, wie die sich Woche für Woche zeigen. Jetzt fairerweise war gegen Liverpool eine Hälfte dabei, die die Beste war in der Saison, aber in jedem Fall unter Juric. Fairerweise, es gibt keine Konkurrenz. Also alle anderen Spiele sind mitunter, das ist wahnsinnig witzig, was die da verbrechen an Fehlern und so weiter. Und es ist nicht gesagt und bei Southampton selbst haben sie auch die Angst davor, dass die vielleicht einfach gar nicht mehr punkten, wenn es so weitergeht.
Und also hat schon mal jemand die Jahresbilanz oder die Saisonbilanz von Ivan Juric gerade ausgerechnet? Also bei der Roma waren es vier Siege mit Southampton, waren es jetzt zwei Siege in 13 Städten für Southampton und 12 für die Roma, also 25. Und er hat immerhin sechs Mal davon gewinnen können. Aber also hat das mit ihm zu tun oder ist das jetzt ungerecht, wenn ich da eine Verbindung herziehe? Aber Matsumes hat mich angefunkt, ich soll das nochmal kurz ansprechen.
Ist er ein Influencer jetzt?
Was Ivan Juric angeht schon, da hat er eine Meinung hab ich gehört.
Ich glaube, der hat generell Meinungen. Also es hängt auch mit Juric zusammen. Wir haben im Podcast bei Bekanntgabe gesagt, es war ein bisschen random, die Verpflichtung seinerzeit, als der auf Russell Martin gefolgt ist, entweder das wird eine wundersame Rettung oder das ändert in einer Massenschlägerei. Und im Moment ist die Massenschlägerei wieder sehr viel näher, weil es schon wieder Berichte gibt, dass er sich mit den allergrößten Teilen des Kaders derart gefetzt hat, dass das eigentlich gar nicht mehr weitergeht. Ich habe eigentlich Montag, Dienstag immer nur gewartet, dass jetzt die Entlassung bekannt gegeben wird. Die haben auch schon vorsichtshalber jemanden hochgezogen, der als Interimstrainer übernehmen könnte. Der Nachfolger in Danny Röhl, der schon mal gearbeitet hat unter Hasenmüttel, soll schon feststehen. Ehrlicherweise, also der Vergleich, der da ist, der noch aus der bis dato letzten Premier League Saison kommt, ist Nathan Jones, den sie verpflichtet haben, warum auch immer damals. Und das ging bodenlos schief. Plus, der hat die mit unter wildesten Pressekonferenzen gegeben, die ich jemals in meinem Leben von einem Trainer gehört hab. Und alles, was die Fans schreiben, unisono, das ist der kroatische Nathan Jones. Insofern ist auch unter Juric nichts besser geworden. Ich habe grundsätzlich die Idee verstanden, dass man einmal kehrt machen möchte zu dem Russell Martin Fußball, der besagt hat religiös von hinten rausspielen kostet, was es wolle und im Notfall auch mal fünf Gegentore in einer Partie nach Ballverlust beim eigenen Aufbau. Das habe ich grundsätzlich verstanden. Es ist aber nicht besser geworden. Im Gegenteil, man könnte sogar argumentieren, dass die Schlüsselspieler und da muss man jetzt aber wieder fairerweise dazu sagen, die sind jung, dass die Schlüsselspieler und der Juric sogar schwächer geworden sind.
Okay, das klingt alles wirklich gar nicht gut und ist das eine Geschichte, die... also wie hohe Wellen schlägt das? Weil man kann es ja unter verschiedenen Aspekten sehen. Southampton hat ja auch, ich meine die Geschichte in der Premier League und ja nicht immer Premier League, die war ja auch sehr wechselhaft und mit Letoissier habe ich ja schon mit auf die beste Zeit referiert, die zumindest quasi langfristig die beste Zeit von Southampton war. Aber was ist das, wie wird das diskutiert drüben in England?
Also national kannst du dir vorstellen, relativ wenig, weil sich eigentlich alle ab November damit abgefunden haben, die werden sagen und klar und los absteigen, chancenlos sein. Aber und das ist jetzt schon wieder, deshalb habe ich das Thema jetzt auch mitgebracht, Dragon Schollack ist der Hauptgeldgeber dort, gemeinsam mit Sports Republic Rasmus Ankersson, ehemals Brentford, der viel zu tun hat mit diesem datenorientierten Aufstieg von Brentford. Das sind die starken Leute da und seitdem Sports Republic übernommen hat und auch die Historie der Besitzer ist übrigens sehr, sehr wechselhaft und unterschiedlich gut gegangen. Aber die haben übernommen mit dem Ziel, den Verein so wieder aufzustellen, wie er mal war in der bis dato letzten Phase der Premier League Zugehörigkeit, die er lange Zeit angedauert hat, über ein Jahrzehnt und die auch erfolgreich war, so erfolgreich, dass die sogar mitunter im Pokalfinals standen und so weiter und so weiter. Nur hat vorne und hinten nicht geklappt, im Gegenteil, ich würde sagen und da ist dann vor allen Dingen aber regional die der Blick schon sehr stark drauf. Das ist die wahrscheinlich schlimmste Zeit Southampton-Fans zu sein, weil der bis dato letzte Abstieg war schon echt so, dass die Vereinskultur arg angegriffen worden ist. Sehr, sehr negative Grundstimmung in einem an sich ziemlich positiven Premier League Standort. Die Verkäufe sind eingebrochen. Mitunter sind auch die Ticketkäufe ausgeblieben. Und im Grunde eigentlich ist das ein Hasenhüttel, wenn man es mal auf den Punkt bringen will. Das war wahrscheinlich die schlechteste Entscheidung kurz vor der WM damals. Das haben wir hier besprochen, dass ich das schon eine Zeit lang wusste, dass sie das vorhaben, den zu entlassen. Seither eigentlich nichts mehr richtig gemacht. Jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen, klar, die Champions-Saison, die war grundpositiv insgesamt. Da war eine klare Idee zu erkennen, der Russell Martin, aber halt auch nur Aufstieg über die Playoffs mit einem Kader, der schon Premier League Geld kostet und wahrscheinlich auch Premier League Qualität hatte. Ganz kurz Erleichterung für die, die es mit dem Verein halten und dann ging es aber in die Premier League rein. Und im Grunde Abspielminute eins war klar, die werden hier, die werden gnadenlos, gnadenlos baden gehen. Sehr naiv im Ansatz und das ist dann wiederum schon ein Thema. Und Schollack, um den ganz langen Satz jetzt zu Ende zu machen mit vielen Kommata, Schollack hat jetzt angekündigt, so geht es nicht weiter. Er nimmt sich jetzt der Sache selbst an. Dem sagt man nach, dass er ein sehr eigener Typ ist. Dekadenterweise hat er die Mannschaft, zum Beispiel also nur ein kleiner Exkurs, vor dem Playoff-Finale eingeladen auf seine Jacht und hat eine riesen Party geschmissen, gesagt, wenn ihr aufsteigt, dann verdopple ich diese Party. Das heißt, der kann hands-on sein und das wiederum wird aber aus meiner Sicht bedeuten, ganz sicher ist das aber nicht, wird aus meiner Sicht bedeuten, dass Sports Republic im Drasmus Ankersen und dem sehr datenorientierten Ansatz etwas nach hinten gerät. Das heißt, wahrscheinlich etwas im Durchschnitt älter eingekauft wird und so weiter. Die haben jetzt einen technischen Direktor geholt, den Johannes Spohr, Deutscher, ehemals 777 Group. Er soll ein sehr talentierter Funktionär sein. Ich hab leider noch nicht mit ihm sprechen können. Ich bin dran, dass er mir, ich weiß nicht, ob er das macht, aber vielleicht mal ein paar Insights gibt in dem Verein, was er vorhat und so weiter. Er hat auf jeden Fall jetzt eine spannende, aber auch extrem anstrengende Aufgabe vor sich. Soweit kann man sagen. Also ich würde tippen, dass da einiges passiert jetzt bei Southampton. Das wird nicht mehr der gleiche Verein sein.
Okay, wir werden es langfristig auf dem Schirm haben, was da bei Southampton passiert und all diejenigen, die mit Metalheadest hier nichts anfangen können, einfach mal bei YouTube eingeben. Mit die besten Freistöße. Also David Beckham war nur ein Wiedergänger von ihm. Könnte man vielleicht ein bisschen kettelig sagen.
Jetzt geh ich aber gleich raus hier.
Ich weiß doch wo ich dich pieksen muss.
Das ist falsch. Fake News.
Aber es waren sehr sehr schöne und ja einer der erfolgreichsten Elfmeterschütze, wenn nicht sogar der erfolgreichste der Premier League Geschichte. Und angesprochen auf sein Erfolgsrezept hat er nicht wie Harry Kane gesagt, ja ich hab meine Routine, ich bereite mich immer vor und so weiter. Er hat gesagt, wichtig ist, dass man nicht nur platziert schießt, sondern einfach sauhart, dann sind eigentlich die meisten drin. Und dann schaut euch seine Elfmeter an, genau so war's. Ich hab mal für Freunde einen Text über ihn geschrieben, deswegen hab ich mich da sehr sehr lange eingegraben. Und obwohl das 2008 war, ist das alles einfach noch da. Medle Tessier, guter Mann. So, wir gehen in die Blitzrunde sag ich jetzt mal. Wir springen jetzt ein bisschen schneller zwischen den Ligen. Alex, wenn wir nach Spanien blicken, was hast du uns denn noch mitgebracht?
Ja leider eine sehr schlimme tragische Geschichte, die man kurz hier erwähnen muss. Ich glaube, die hat in Deutschland ja eh die Runde gemacht, aber der vollständigkeitshalber, weil es eben die große Story des Wochenendes war, beim FC Barcelona ist der Teamarzt verstorben, unglücklich vor dem Spiel. Gab eine Tragödie. Carles Mignardo Garcia ist im Hotel quasi in der Vorbereitung aufs Spiel. Ja, verstorben ist beim Nickerchen offenbar eingeschlafen, nicht mehr aufgewacht, ganz, ganz tragisch. Und das Spiel in der Liga wurde dann ganz kurzfristig abgesagt. Ich glaube, halbe Stunde, 20 Minuten vor Spielbeginn, 21 Uhr Samstagabend wurde das dann abgesagt, das Spiel, weil die Mannschaft natürlich komplett unter Schock stand. War ja sehr, sehr nah dran. Ist ja bei jedem Spiel, bei jedem Auswärtsheimspiel dabei. Also das ist für Menschen, die nicht so im Umfeld eines Vereins sind, wahrscheinlich schwieriger zu greifen. Nur ein Teamarzt, nee, der gehört schon zum Team, des Teams dazu. Und deswegen war die Mannschaft natürlich komplett geschockt. Und La Liga hat dann dieses Spiel kurzfristig abgesagt, war natürlich auch aus sportlicher Sicht jetzt interessant zu sehen, wie reagiert das Team auf diesen Schock, weil sie ja zwei Tage später das Champions League Spiel hatten. Und um jetzt den Bogen zu spannen, ganz kurz aufs Sportliche, sie haben sehr, sehr gut reagiert. Sie haben Benfica chancenlos drei zu eins besiegt und vor allem die Art und Weise in der ersten Halbzeit war beeindruckend. Weiß nicht, ob man sagen kann, man hat auch für ihn gespielt, aber es gab wohl, ja, es gab natürlich eine Schweigeminute und auch Spieler, die ab und zu nach oben gezeigt haben beim Torjubel. Also da war schon, glaube ich, so ein bisschen besondere Flair dann im Stadion und, ja, die sportliche Reaktion war schon auch sehr, sehr, sehr interessant zu sehen, denn du kannst natürlich auch ganz anders reagieren, wenn dich das so mitnimmt, da den Fokus aufs Sportliche zu legen, dann wieder zwei Tage später, wenn du einen Teammember verloren hast, ist auch nicht so leicht, finde ich bemerkenswert. Und ja, das ist so die kleine Side-Story aus Spanien, die ich mitgebracht habe.
Weil Barca der Gegner von Dortmund ist, muss ich diese eine Rückfrage dann doch noch stellen. Wird Hansi Fluck Flick gegen den BVB die erste Niederlage im Kalenderjahr 2025 mit Barca erleben?
Ja, spannende Frage. Gestern hat der BVB wieder einen besseren Eindruck gemacht, ein anderes Gesicht gezeigt, hat mir sehr, sehr gut gefallen in Lille. Vielleicht ihr bestes Spiel seit Monaten gezeigt. Und da sieht man wieder in der Champions League, finden sie immer wieder so Abende, wenn das Wutlicht an ist, wenn die Hymne ertönt. Da sind dann Kräfte in diesem Team beim BVB, die man in der Bundesliga Woche Week in, Week out einfach nicht sieht. Das ist schon irgendwie bemerkenswert, auch ein bisschen unlogisch, unerklärbar, warum sie das immer wieder finden. Klar, es war nur Lille, die waren auch nicht so gut. Das gehört natürlich auch immer dazu, auch Benfica war nicht so gut. Aber das ist schon bemerkenswert. Ich glaube, unterschätzen sollte man den BVB nicht, denn die Favoritenrolle ist klar, Anabasah ist ganz klarer Favorit aufs Weiterkommen. Auch weil der BVB so eine schwache Saison spielt. Aber man sieht in der Champions League, mit dem BVB muss man immer rechnen. Vor allem haben sie das Rückspiel zu Hause in Dortmund. Da weiß man, letztes Jahr haben sie Atletico da eliminiert, marschierten bis ins Finale, ohne dass man wusste, wie. Von daher, vielleicht ist es nicht ganz so klar, wie man es vorher dachte.
Ja, interessant, ich hab ja gesagt, die Blitzrunde und ich hätte mich jetzt auch nicht gewundert, wenn du einfach sagst nein und wir hätten weitergemacht, dann hätte ich auch nicht weiter nachgefragt. Es geht auf jeden Fall interessant weiter für Barca jetzt erst mal nämlich bei Atletico in La Liga und gegen die wird man auch im Copa del Rey Halbfinale ja dann nochmal spielen. Nur da erinnern wir uns an das 4 zu 4 Hinspiel. Also Barca, wir haben es ja eh alle im Blick und mit dem BVB jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr. Wir sind immer sehr gespannt darauf, was da noch passiert. Daniel, was wollen wir aus der Eredivisie noch besprechen?
Wir gucken nochmal in die internationale Wettbewerb, in die CEL und die EL, da muss man nämlich auch sagen, es gibt so mehrere kleine Geschichten verpackt in den letzten ein, zwei Wochen. Und zwar ist eine davon für PSV Eindhoven, denn vergangenen Woche gegen Asen, das lief ja nicht so gut mit dem 7 zu 1 für Eindhoven. Das heißt, da war die Luft ja für das Spiel jetzt zwei, zwei Jahre eigentlich schon raus. Und trotzdem hatten die Fans von Eindhoven eigentlich einen sehr schönen Tag, haben eine schöne Zeit in London, denn Eindhoven war so nett und hat die Kosten, die Ticketkosten, das waren ab 2000 Fans, die mitgereist sind nach London und die haben eine E-Mail erhalten vom Verein, weil steht ja für die, für diese 7 zu 1 kommen wir für die Kosten auf, für das Auswärtsspiel jetzt in London. Die Fans waren zuvor noch beim LFC Wimbledon, haben ein bisschen Quadrope machen können und hatten auch während des Spiels gegen Arsenal eigentlich immer irgendwas zu feiern, immer haben immer gejubelt, auch gegen Gegentoren, das war denen vollkommen egal. Die hatten einfach eine schöne Zeit. Das ist ja auch ermöglicht ganz schön und man muss dazu sagen, immerhin ein 2-2 gegen Arsenal, dann auch der Lupfer zum 2-2 zum Ausgleich, ein sehr schönes Tor, schönster zweiter Tages würde ich mal beanspruchen. Und das ist jetzt die nächste Geschichte, das zweite 2 ist insofern auch für die Eredivise nicht schlecht, wegen der UEFA 5-Jahreswertung. Denn da muss die Eredivise ein bisschen aufpassen in den kommenden Jahren. Es ist so, dass durch das Ausscheiden von Winfica, das hat der Eredivise gut getan, dann Portugal ist auf Platz 7 in der 5-Jahreswertung und die Niederlande ist auf Platz 6, das heißt, der direkte Verfolger ist erst mal raus mit Winfica und es gibt ja zumindest noch in der Europa League niederländische Hoffnungen auf Ajax, auch wenn ich die nie so stark sehe gegen Frankfurt und aber auch Hoffnungen für AZ gegen Tottenham. Das Hinspiel 1-0 gewonnen, hätte auch vor diesem ganzen Spiel in der CL und EL nicht gedacht, dass ausgerechnet AZ gegen Tottenham aktuell die besten Karten hat von den Vereinen, die übrigens bei uns sind. Aber da muss ich einmal kurz Klaasie und Kurt Manners rausheben, die wegen Tottenham hinspielen ein Riesenspiel gemacht haben. Und da ist jetzt die Hoffnung drinne, denn um die Torbe-Runde abzufliessen, Belgien auf Platz 8 jagt die Niederlande schon ein bisschen, denn in den nächsten ein, zwei Jahren werden ja die Ergebnisse von den letzten Saisons weggestrichen, 5-Jahres-Wettungen ja immer. Und in der Saison 21-22, da haben die Niederlande 19.000-2-mal Punkte gemacht.
Zwei beste Stimmen in Europa war man damals.
Ja, das lag vor allem auch an Ajax und den 18 Punkten in der CL-Gruppenphase. Und das wird gestrichen. Und bei Belgien in demselben Jahr waren es nur 6.600 oder 6,6 Punkte. Das heißt, da in zwei Jahren ist die Prognose so, dass die Niederlande auf Prang 8 abrutschen, wenn die beiden Autos schlichen werden, hinter Portugal, hinter Belgien. Und das wäre teuer. Das würde uns natürlich den dritten CL-Qualifikats kosten in der Liga, unter anderem. Und deswegen aus unserer Sicht, aus RRDV-Sicht, heißt das Daumen drücken für Ajax und für AZ, auch wenn das sicherlich Uli nicht hören will mit Hattenheim. Aber wenn das viele Eintracht-Fans wirklich werden wollen. Aber ja, das ist so ein bisschen das Roundup der AER an CL.
Also du musst dir keine Sorgen machen, im Rasenfunk wird nicht nach 5-Jahres-Fertung aufgestellt. Hier hast du deinen Platz sicher. Entspann dich. Alles andere kann kommen, wie es kommt. So wie Bissek, der soeben für die Nationalmannschaft nominiert wurde. Pressemitteilung ging gerade raus.
Oh, stark.
Mario hat sich spontan, Mario ist gerade 5 Jahre älter geworden, weil er hat gerade versucht zu dappen. Habe ich das richtig gesehen?
Fünf Jahre sind das länger her, oder? Frau Popper, wie lange ist der gesperrt? Davon ziehst du noch mal drei Jahre ab. So lang ist das her.
Naja, musst du wissen. Wollen wir jetzt über Bissek sprechen? Spontaneinschätzung oder eine andere Personalie, Mario?
Jan Bissek, tatsächlich finde ich es verdient, hat eine Riesenentwicklung gemacht unter Insagi, ist halt auch nicht mehr als nur Rotationsspieler, der hat gerade in der Champions League super oft auch von Beginn an in der Startelf gestanden. Also körperlich bringt er viel mit, der hat schon auch Torgefahr bei Standard Situationen, der spielt ja dann auch auf der Position, auf der Bastian sonst spielt und wenn man sich ein bisschen mit dem Fußball Insagis beschäftigt, kann man glaube ich daraus schließen, dass es ein Spieler ist, der extrem großes taktisches Verständnis jetzt schon entwickelt hat und da aber in den nächsten Jahren, wenn auch bei Inter bleibt, glaube ich, einen guten Lehrmeister hat, um da noch die nächsten Schritte zu gehen. Also finde ich auch mal ehrlicherweise wieder eine mutige Entscheidung von Nagelsmann, auch mal über den Tellerrand rauszugucken und nicht irgendwie den x-beliebigen Bundesligaspieler aus im Blickfeld Kategorie bei Kicker einzuladen oder so. Von daher, ja, genau. Und ansonsten wäre die andere Personalie gewesen, ganz schnell abschließend, weil wir bei ex-Trainer, ex-Weltklasse Fußballern waren, die jetzt Trainer sind, muss den Hut ziehen vor Patrick Vieira. Er hat dann nicht verstanden, warum den Genoa geholt hat für Alberto Ciladino, aber der hat die voll stabilisiert bei 16 Partien, nur viermal verloren. Ja, sind sieben Unentschieden mit dabei, aber inzwischen sind die zehn Punkte vor den Abstiegsrängen. Unter anderem auch, weil sie einen guten Aaron Martin haben, kennen wir noch aus Meinzer Zeit und von Espanol. Der ist mit am häufigsten in der Serie A so am Herausspielen von Torchancen beteiligt, da war der viel Zug nach vorne hat. Krass. Ja, also ein Traditionsclub in Italien, der sich gehalten hat und nächstes Jahr auch mit dabei sein wird.
Stimmt und da war die Situation da wirklich sehr, sehr viel kritischer noch zuletzt. Uli, was hast du uns noch mitgebracht?
Das kommt jetzt darauf an, über was du sprechen willst. Ich hab, lass uns vielleicht einmal ganz schnell nur, damit der Name auch mal gefallen ist, liebe Grüße an Hasan Salihamidzic. Ich treffe keinen Menschen in der Stadt in München öfter als Hasan Salihamidzic. Das ist einfach krass.
Du bist eindeutig in den falschen Regionen unterwegs in München.
Der ist einfach überall. Der lebt, glaube ich, das darf man vielleicht sagen.
Also hier in Giesing war er noch nie. Ich hab ihn hier noch nie getroffen.
Okay, gut. Ja, fair enough. Aber wenn ich mich irgendwie in Richtung Stadt begebe, dann hängt er da immer irgendwo rum. Aber er ist ein netter Kerl.
Und welchen Namen hast du da immer im Ohr, wenn du ihn triffst?
Ich denke automatisch, also wechselseitig, sowohl wenn ich Karl-Heinz Nordeuil sehe, denke ich an Sali Hamidzic, als auch wenn ich Sali Hamidzic sehe, denke ich automatisch an Karl-Heinz Nordeuil. Und wahrscheinlich freut sich jetzt Hasan Sali Hamidzic, der ist ja sicherlich Rasenfunk-Hörer und supporter. Wahrscheinlich freut er sich jetzt, dass er spät dann doch noch Recht bekommen hat in seiner Einschätzung zu seinem einzigen Wunschspieler, den er unbedingt zu Bayern holen wollte für Gelder. Und seinerzeit hab ich nicht so ganz verstanden, was er damit wollte. Ist auch immer noch ein bisschen zu hoch gegriffen, aber ist in überragender Form und ich geh sogar so weit, dass ich sage, das ist im Moment, also ganz im Moment, der beste links außen der Premier League, der es einfach sehr, sehr, sehr gut macht, passt perfekt ins Spielsystem von Nottingham Forest. Das ist sehr transitionslastig, ist aber, hat seine Schnelligkeit, trifft im Moment, hat jetzt glaube ich drei Tore in den letzten vier Spielen gemacht, ist in Sachen erfolgreichen Dribblings, das variiert immer mal, Top 2, aber bis Top 5 noch nicht aus der 6 raus, probiert auch relativ viel, ist ein überragender Distanzschütze geworden. Das hat mich sehr verwundert, weil ich das zu Beginn seiner Karriere so nicht drin stehen hatte, aber ich glaube, müssten sieben sein, die er aus der Ferne gemacht hat seit Beginn der Saison 23, 24. Und ist einer von vielen bei Nottingham Forest, bei denen ich sagen würde, die performen einfach gnadenlos über individuell und so kommt dann auch der Mannschaftserfolg zustande. Also hätte ich nicht gedacht und er hat jetzt auch neulich, das ist vielleicht noch abschließend ganz nett, hat jetzt nur nach dem Spiel gesagt, wir müssen bescheiden bleiben, dann können wir das auch schaffen mit der Champions-League-Qualifikation. Ist insofern bemerkenswert, dass man ihm in seiner Chelsea-Zeit eine ganz schlechte Arroganz vorgeworfen hat. Das ist glaube ich in England häufiger mal ein schmaler Grad zwischen Selbstbewusstsein und Arroganz. Man wird ja in England als junger Spieler insbesondere in so Reputationsakademien wie Chelsea dazu erzogen, dass man sehr, sehr selbstbewusst rausgeht und nicht sagt naja wenn wir es gut machen, könnten wir, sondern nein wir werden. Das ist Lehrmeinung im Kopf und das hat er immer verkörpert. Und jetzt wird sie mal positiv ausgelegt, früher war es immer negativ. Ist wie es ist, aber es finde ich eine sehr bemerkenswerte Entwicklung. Ich dachte nämlich auch die Karriere ist eigentlich durch, habe auch aus Chelsea gehört, dass es ihm körperlich nicht sehr gut gegangen sein soll eine ganze Zeit lang. Hatte der echt Schwierigkeiten mit Gen alleine geschweige denn laufen. Umso schöner, dass er jetzt sogar sein Potenzial entfaltet. Das habe ich nicht mehr kommen sehen.
Aber wirklich, da hätte man, das hätte man nicht so erwartet. Diese Entwicklung, wenn man sich auch nochmal an die Leverkusener Zeit zurück erinnert.
Stimmt, das war ja auch noch da.
Wir haben ihn ja in der Bundesliga gesehen und da war ja dann eigentlich der Eintest, dass man sich gesagt hat, da kann Hasan Salihamidzic aber froh sein, das nicht und so weiter und so fort. Aber so ist es eben. Und irgendwann wird auch der Innenverteidiger vom 1. FC Köln für die deutsche Nationalmannschaft nominiert. Das sind Geschichten, die ausschließlich ihr wisst es und so weiter und so fort. Blicken wir nochmal nach Spanien, Alex.
Ja, ich hab eine Anti-Hero-Story, eine ganz kleine. Denn An Angel Correa hat eine längere Sperre bekommen beim Spiel am Wochenende gegen Retafel. Das hat Aledigo verloren. In der 90. kommt er zu spät. Gibt nur eine gelbe, war vielleicht dunkelgelb, wie auch immer war, greift ein, zeigt einen natürlichen Standbild, sieht dann etwas rabiater aus, das faul. Schiedsrichter zeigt dann doch rot.
Ich hab irgendwie das Gefühl, dass der VR-Kritik drinsteckt, aber mach einfach mal weiter.
Und dann brennen André Correa die Sicherungen durch und dann beleidigt er den Schiedsrichter aus zwei Metern Entfernung, lautstark, also komplett, völlig banane, mit verschiedensten Beleidigungen, Chio de Puta etc. und weiter und so fort. Und er bekam jetzt eine insgesamt fünf Spiele-Sperre, einen Spielsperre für das Faul und vier Spiele für die Schiedsrichterbeleidigung. Richtig heftig und ein bisschen also natürlich gerechtfertigt, nicht falsch verstehen. Aber interessant ist der Kontext, wofür und wann welcher Spieler, für was eine Sperre kriegt und wann nicht. Also absolut berechtigt. Ich hatte auch beim Tiki Taka Podcast eine ähnliche Sperre prognostiziert. Also wundert mich nicht, dass es vier, fünf Spiele sind. Aber man erinnert sich Bellingham im Liga-Derby vor wenigen Wochen hat den Linienrichter angeschrien, fuck you und fuck off ganz klar zu ihm in seine Richtung. Das hat man sogar auf den Stadion-Mikrofon gehört. Da gab es dann gar nichts. Dann zwei Wochen später wurde Bellingham für ein fuck off, dass er so vor sich hin brabbelt, für zwei Spiele gesperrt, weil der Schiedsrichter ein fuck you gehört haben wollte. Es war aber ein fuck off, wie der Uli weiß das ja in der englischen Kultur, das sagt man tausendmal in jedem Spiel. Da wurde er dann gesperrt mit zwei Spielen. Ja, Korea kriegt jetzt vier. Lewandowski hat mal zwei Spiele letztes Jahr bekommen, weil er gar nichts gesagt hat, sondern sich nur an die Nase gedeutet hat. Wegen der Schiri ist ein bisschen arrogant. Zack, zwei Spiele, Sperre. Also es ist schon interessant, wofür du mal was bekommst und mal nicht. Aber ja, Korea ist natürlich selbst schuld. Du kannst den Schiri nicht beleidigen. Brauchen wir uns nicht falsch verstehen. Aber, Mario, was zu sagen sehe ich.
Ich muss tatsächlich mal, weil man immer denkt, so weil man diese zwei, drei Spiele sperren gewohnt ist. Findet ihr vier Spiele für Hiro de Puta viel?
Ich find's wenig. Ich hab da neulich wieder drüber nachgedacht. Neulich ging wieder mal wieder so ein Video rum von Rugby-Schiedsrichtern und wie die mit den Spielern umgehen. Und es ist nicht komplett zu vergleichen, weil Rugby ist ein Spiel, das oft unterbrochen wird. Deswegen hast du auch als Spieler die Chance, dass du dich kurz setteln kannst. Deswegen ist es ein bisschen unfällig der Vergleich. Aber der Unterschied ist so frappierend. In Deutschland, nee nicht in Deutschland, im Fußball, Quatsch. Und vor allem im Männerfußball wird einfach bei jedem Quatsch laufen fünf Leute zum Schiedsrichter hin. Die Kapitänsregel wird schon wieder gar nicht mehr eingehalten, aber auch weil die Schiedsrichter sie nicht durchsetzen. Also Felix Zweier steht offenbar da drauf, Podcasts zu machen mit Spielern. Also da fällt mir das immer ganz besonders auf. Aber ich finde grundsätzlich ist es einfach absolut albern, was inzwischen passiert an Seitenlinien. Und zwar auch bei Szenen, wo man sich denkt, das muss jetzt nicht sein, selbst wenn du unter Druck stehst. Xabi Alonso regt sich über ein Faul an der Seitenlinie, also was gepfiffen wird, das wäre eine Balleroberung von Leverkusen gewesen, aber noch 40 Meter von Tor weg regt er sich so auf, dass er die gelbe Karte bekommt. Und ich verstehe, dass der unter Druck steht, aber sorry, wir alle haben Situationen, in denen wir uns im Griff haben müssen, in denen wir aber unter Druck stehen. Ich finde, dass es wenig ist. Das mit der Vergleichbarkeit ist natürlich ein interessanter Punkt und da gibt es natürlich gerade jetzt, was La Liga angeht, ja auch noch Nebengeschichten, was eben Schiedsrichter und so weiter und Bayer und so weiter angeht. Aber ich finde es eigentlich unglaublich, dass so eine Grundrespektlosigkeit einfach immer da ist und die akzeptiert wird, obwohl man jetzt versucht hat, gegen vorzugehen mit den gelben Karten für die Offiziellen und für Trainer, Mitsperren für Trainer. Steffen Baumgart setzt sich in die Pressekonferenz nach Eintracht Frankfurt gegen Union Berlin. Ich meine, der zieht ja sowieso immer eine Fresse und ja, ich habe mir sagen lassen, das soll die Berliner Schnauze sein. Aber das ist doch unglaublich einfach, dass jemand so rumrotzen kann. Von der ganzen Attitüde her immer nur zeigen kann, ihr alle seid doof und das sagt er ja auch den Schiedsrichtern und dann beschwert er sich darüber, dass es dafür gelbe Karten gibt. Ja, also das ist doch, also sorry, jetzt hast du gerade bei mir auf einen, das war mein David Beckham, du hast gerade bei mir auf den Button gedrückt, deswegen habe ich sie hier kurz gekapert. Also ich finde, das ist ein riesen Thema und das nervt mich unglaublich.
Es ist jetzt natürlich eine größere Sache, ein größeres Thema. Kontext ist natürlich die Kultur und Fluchkultur in den verschiedenen Ländern. Also wenn wir Ulli hier haben in England, fuck you, fuck off, glaube ich vor allem fuck off, sagen die Spieler ständig so vor sich hin und brabbeln zum Gegner.
Kommt darauf an, in welchem Teil Englands.
Wahrscheinlich, aber da ist es einfach normal. Stell dir vor, da gäbe es immer rot, dann würde kein Spiel zu Ende gespielt werden. In Spanien ist die Fluchkultur auch sehr ausgeprägt, dass man ständig Jijo de Puta und so sagt auch vor sich hin, hundertmal beim Spielfeld, das wird da nicht immer mit geahndet, weil es einfach zu Kultur gehört, die einfach sehr derbe ist. Gleichzeitig solltest du es natürlich nicht dem Schiedsrichter ins Gesicht sagen und das hat eben Correa gemacht, also der den ganz klar beleidigt auch mit drei Sachen am Stück. Also es war nicht nur nicht nur Jijo de Puta, sondern mehr, wenn man es aber dann jetzt auf Deutschland anwendet und das hast du ja gerade gemacht, Max, ist es unvorstellbar, dass du zum Schiedsrichter F dich du hu... so und sagen würdest. Das ist natürlich, das wäre ein Monsterskandal. Also wir haben auch eine andere, nicht vorhandene Fluchkultur. Bei uns sagt man halt Scheiße und leckt mich am Arsch und das war's. Aber in Spanien ist das Scheiße und leckt mich am Arsch. Halt eher das.
Du kannst mal in meine Insta-DM gucken. Also Fluchkultur ist ja schon durchaus aufgegeben.
Also ich glaube nicht durch Spieler auf dem Spielfeld, das wollte ich sagen.
Ich glaube es geht auch um dieses ins Gesicht rein sagen. Aber ich also bei Korea schon.
Aber generell, also ich habe ein Video gesehen vor ein paar Wochen, da ging es um die um die Bellingham-Sperre, Nichtsperre und seine Aussagen. Da war ein Zusammenschnitt wie Barca mit Messi Neymar und Suarez rumgeflucht hat. Noch und nöcher. Da gab es nie irgendwas. Also Luis Suarez vor allem, auch kein Kind von Traurigkeit. Viele Jahre her, klar, hat da Linienrichter und Schiedsrichter beleidigt in einer Tour. Die standen halt nicht einen Meter neben ihm, sondern halt an der Seitenlinie. Aber da gab es nie irgendwelche Sperrungen oder irgendwas, weil in Spanien das halt einfach dazu gehört. Jetzt kann man sagen, leider, fälschlicherweise. Aber ja, deswegen ist es umso bemerkenswerter, dass er jetzt dann die vier Spiele bekommt, was natürlich richtig ist, weil er hat ganz klar dem Schiedsrichter gesagt, da stand auch nur zwei Metern vor ihm der Schiri. Aber trotzdem im Gesamtkontext schon eine spannende Geschichte.
Ja, also ich will es jetzt nicht noch größer machen, aber man könnte da dann auch eben drüber sprechen. Also gegen Hatespeech und so weiter setzen sich jetzt alle Ligen ein und so weiter. Aber wo fängt es denn an und wo hört es auf? Und ich sage das, das möchte ich vielleicht noch mit dazu sagen. Nicht, dass es hier so rüberkommt, als wäre ich ein Engel. Ich war ein ganz fürchterlicher Scheisspieler, als ich noch Fußball gespielt habe. Ich habe oft gelbe Karten wegen Meckerns gesehen. Weil ich manchmal auch die Regeln ein bisschen besser kannte. Ehrlich gesagt, dass die Schiedsrichter, ich habe immer auf der untersten Niveau gespielt, aber jede der gelben Karten war gerechtfertigt. Ich war einer auch, der immer alles musste raus und ich musste das aber halt dann auch lernen, dass man manchmal, vielleicht auch mal anerkennt, dass es halt der Schiedsrichter...
Was rundet mich jetzt doch, muss ich sagen.
Ja du, ich habe eine Fußballpersonen-Persönlichkeit, ihr könnt ja euch gar nicht vorstellen. Müssen wir uns mal zum Kicken treffen.
Ich bin ja auch immer als Spieler die Tatsache ausgenutzt, dass ich ja selber Schiri war und ich wusste, wann er wohin guckt. Also ich war auch eine fiese Ratte, muss ich sagen, auf dem Platz. Und bin aber immer der, der zum Schiri und neben dem Schiri dann so gesagt hat, wenn ein Mitspieler gemeckert hat, so hey, nee, hat er richtig gesehen. Und dann dachte der Schiri, ah, das ist einer für immer.
Das sind ja alles samt überraschende Bekenntnisse, muss ich sagen.
Wobei, so eine Ratte war ich nicht. Ich hab also bei so Faust und so weiter, ich hab ja immer Libere gespielt, deswegen, ich hatte schon oft quasi die Gegenspieler und die haben ja auch gesehen, wie ich so von der Statur her bin. Das heißt, mit Körperlichkeit konntest du mir schon beikommen. Den Rest hatte ich ganz gut drauf. Ich hab nur reagiert. Also ich ganz oft natürlich irgendwie Schiri schaut nicht und dann kriegst du irgendwie so einen mit oder bei der Ecke steigen sie dir halt mit dem Stollen auf den C und so weiter. Dann hab ich immer gesagt, okay, du machst das genau noch einmal und dann lass ich bei der Grätsche das Knie oben, weil da im Pferdekuss und so weiter und so fort. Das hab ich aber halt dann auch gemacht, ehrlicherweise.
Stille Wasser sind tief, merk ich da an. Also geht mir nicht so.
Alex, kann ich dich belegen?
Alex, respektiert Schiedsrichter.
Ne, tue ich tatsächlich, weil ich selber schon Spiele gepfiffen hab und dann weiß ich, wie schwer das ist. Und ich bin auch Trainer im Amateurbereich aktuell und ich hab noch nie eine gelbe Karte wie ein Meckerns gesehen. Weil wenn ich mich aufreg, mach ich es immer sachlich und erklär ihm immer, was er falsch gemacht hat. Aber immer sachlich. Ne, also ich sag halt dann ja, du musst Geld geben, weil das ist ein klares taktisches Foul. Das machst du natürlich auch laut, aber immer sachlich. Also es ist nie, nie beleidigend oder nie in irgendwie angehend, sondern immer laut, okay, aber sachlich. Und deswegen, ich hab noch nie Geld gegen, wegen Meckern weder als Spieler noch als Trainer gesehen. Von daher.
Stark. Der Anti-Steffen Baumgart, finde ich sehr, sehr gut. Kannst du nicht bitte nächste Union Trainer werden?
Ich fände es übrigens gut, dass dieser Name jetzt zweimal gefallen ist, weil das diese Woche bei uns auch schon Thema war und diese Art und Weise, wie eine vermeintliche kultige Art und Weise mit Menschen umzugehen, da gerade auf die Spitze getrieben wird und wie respektlos da mit JournalistInnen umgegangen wird und auch mit Schiedsrichtern von Seiten des Unionstrenners ist wohnlos.
Was ich übrigens mache, wenn ich sauer auf dem Schiri bin, weil der mich vermeintlich verpfiffen hat, ich verweige den Handschlag nach dem Spiel, dann gehe ich nicht hin und gebe ihm nicht die Hand. Das ist aber auch Quatsch. Also die sind ja wirklich schlecht.
Nach dem Spiel ist es vorbei, Alex.
Nach dem Spiel muss man auch so vom Feld gehen, dass man dann, du musst, also ich hatte auch schon richtig, richtig üble und wir hatten auch die Spiele mit irgendwie Massenschlägerei und einmal hat unser Torhüter mich davor bewahrt, dass ich aus dem Maul gekommen hab. Danke nochmal, Armin. Weil es ist halt einfach der Provinz-Fußball und dann gibt's ja die entsprechenden Gegner und die sogenannten Derbys, bla bla bla. Aber du musst danach vom Feld gehen so, dass du der gegnerischen Mannschaften einen Bierkasten hinstellen kannst und sagen kannst, so der ist für euch. Das nächste Mal.
Da ergibt man sich die Hand.
Das muss schon sein, weil du, ich hatte das auch schon hier bei dem Spiel, wo mir aufs Maul hätte gehauen werden sollen. Da haben die dann abends sind sie dann gekommen, zu SIPT sind irgendwie vor die Turnhalle, weil da war irgendeine Faschingsfeier und haben gesagt, der soll jetzt mal rauskommen, wir regeln das noch. Die wollten das quasi weiterführen und das darf einfach nicht passieren. Weil bei so was passieren auch schlimme Sachen. Einer hat ein Messer dabei. Das ist einfach so. Sorry to say, das heißt irgendwann muss es beendet werden. Und auch mit den Schiedsrichtern. Ich hab den Schiedsrichtern, also ich war auch immer oder oft Kapitän und so weiter, hab eh viel mit denen. Und nach dem Spiel war immer alles in Ordnung. Da hab ich dann auch manchmal gesagt, es tut mir leid, vorhin die Gelbe war richtig. Ich hatte in dem Moment das Gefühl, ich muss das sagen.
Da geh ich hundertprozentig mit nach dem Spiel, aber nach dem Spiel ist halt eine halbe Stunde, Stunde, zwei Stunden nach dem Spiel, wenn sich's beruhigt hat, das Ganze. Aber direkt mit Schlusspfiff ist nicht nach dem Spiel, das ist da immer noch.
Mit Schlusspfiff muss es sicher erledigt haben.
Dann ist es auch Selbstschutz, damit mir nicht der Kontertuchel-Handschlag passiert. Aber nicht falsch verstehen. Es ist nicht so, dass der Schiri auf einen zukommt und dann verweigt meinen Handschlag. Ich geh halt einfach nicht zum Schiedsrichter. Ich würde wirklich so sauer sein sollte, was jetzt nicht häufig passiert. Weil dann geh ich halt einfach nicht zum Schiri, weil wenn ich der Meinung bin, dass mich der Pfiffen, aber Selbstschutz, so kann mir halt auch nichts rausrutschen. So pfeife ich ihm nichts, so sage ich ihm nicht, was ich von seiner Leistung halte.
Dann kriegst du nicht mehr gerettet.
Man trifft die doch so oft wieder. Also ich hatte bei mir den Fall, dass wir dann gespielt haben und bei uns...
Die Schiedsrichter mögen mich, Max.
Da stand der Vettel. Der Vettel ist immer nicht gesprungen. Deswegen, wenn die Gegner das gecheckt haben, dann fingen die Gegentoranwärter, haben die aus 40 Metern ins Eck geschossen und der Vettel hat versucht, hinzulaufen und er ist nicht hingekommen. Und dann ist er auch einmal wieder nicht hingekommen und hat dem gegnerischen Spieler den Ball ins Gesicht geworfen und hat gesagt, du Blöder, ich möchte es nicht weiter zitieren. Und der Schiedsrichter geht hin und ich denke mir so, ja gut, geil, jetzt darf einer von uns Tor. Null Bock. Hab schon überlegt, ob es ich machen muss. Dann gibt er ihm gelb und nach dem Spiel dann, wir verlieren irgendwie keine Ahnung, eins zu acht oder irgendwie so war ganz, ganz düster. Waren auch wieder ein paar Leute, die auf dem Beinfest waren und so weiter. Also auch nicht überraschend. Und nach dem Spiel gehe ich hin zum Schiedsrichter und sage, Schiri, danke, dass sie dem Vettel nur rot gegeben haben, weil das hätte das Ganze hier noch wilder gemacht. Und das war ja sowieso eindeutig. Und da hat der Schiri einfach nur gesagt, ich kenne doch den Vettel. Weil der uns schon fünf Mal gepfiffen hat in den letzten Jahren und der wusste ja, meine Güte ist halt so. Und deswegen musst du den Schiedsrichtern schon die Hand geben, Alex. Du siehst die doch immer wieder auf der Ebene.
Ja, die mögen mich aber drohen.
Ist ein gutes Zeichen auch übrigens.
Ist ein gutes Zeichen, aber wie gesagt eben der Emotion im Affekt und der Schlusspfiff ist ja immer noch, da ist ja gehören noch zu spiel. Das interessiert doch keinen, aber wie gesagt nach dem Spiel, dann eine Stunde später nach dem Duschen, gehe ich immer in die Kabine, gebe in die Hand, dies das. Alles okay, dann kann man auch sachlich darüber reden, aber beim Schlusspfiff selber, wenn ich der Meinung bin, also wenn die Emotionen hochkochen, dann bleibe ich lieber fern, bevor mir was rausrutscht oder bevor ich unsachlich werde, wobei ich ja nicht unsachlich bin, aber so meint ich es eher, viel eher. Aber die sind schon wirklich schlecht, Max.
Ja, ich, Alex, ich weiß das doch. Alex, ich hatte doch auch die Schiedsrichter, die Regeln nicht kannten und so weiter. So war es bei uns auch so, dass dann der Co-Trainer gepfiffen hat. Und ich habe meinen eigenen Co-Trainer mal erklären müssen, wie das mit Upside's läuft mit, da gab es noch nicht ein liberal Play, aber war eine ähnliche Situation und so weiter und so fort. Natürlich, das ist bodenlos. Also Alex, ich gebe dir jetzt meinen, ich gebe dir jetzt meinen Superhero-Move. Was ich gemacht habe, wenn ich wirklich richtig, richtig gepisst war vom Schiedsrichter und wenn ich wirklich am liebsten gesagt hätte, du Drecksack hast uns hier dieses Spiel verpfiffen und jetzt darf ich mir wieder anhören.
Aber sowas mache ich halt nicht.
Dann gehe ich danach hin und habe gesagt, danke, dass sie es uns ermöglicht haben, dass wir heute spielen können. Das war quasi meine passiv-aggressive Art, dass ich nichts Positives zum Schiri zu sagen hatte, weil ohne den Schiedsrichter gibt es kein Spiel. Da bin ich hingegangen, danke, dass sie gekommen sind, ohne sie hätte es kein Spiel gegeben. Da haben sie dann auch mit geguckt wie ein Auto, aber das war quasi mein Alter hast du heute schlecht gepfiffen.
Die neue Regel ist, dass jemand aus den Mannschaften pfeift.
Ja klar, weil es zu wenig Schiedsrichter gibt. Warum gibt es zu wenig Schiedsrichter? Weil ihnen zu selten die Hand geschüttelt wird nach Abpfiff.
Weiß ich nicht. Aber ich musste tatsächlich letztes Jahr einspringen und ein Spiel pfeifen von unserer Mannschaft, obwohl wir Aussatzmannschaft waren, weil der Schiri nicht kam. Und das war, also kurz eine Anekdote, Spielertrainer war auf der anderen Seite, ich bin Spielertrainer bei uns, aber ich spiele sehr selten und der Spielertrainer von denen war Stammspieler und der Schiri kam nicht. Und dann haben wir uns geeinigt, wer pfeift und ich hab immer gelbe Karte, rote Karten, Pfeife hab ich immer einstecken für genau solche Fälle. Und dann hab ich gesagt, ja dann am fairesten, also ich kann gern pfeifen, wenn du das möchtest. Am fairesten wärs natürlich, dass pro Halbzeit einer aus jeder Mannschaft pfeift, dass es nicht heißt, oh der Auswärtstrainer pfeift die Mannschaft. So haben wir uns darauf geeinigt, ich hab die erste Halbzeit gepfeifen und dann zur Halbzeit der andere Spielertrainer wollte aber nicht pfeifen, weil er selbst gespielt hat, dann haben sie von einem auf einem neben platzenden Schiri, von einem anderen Spiel dazu bekommen, die zweite Halbzeit zu pfeifen, was der gemacht hat, also ein echter Schiri. Und nach dem Spiel kam der Gegner zu mir und hat gesagt, Alex du hast besser gepfeifen als der echte Schiri. Kein Witz, weil der wirklich nicht ganz so gut gepfeift hat.
Hat dir jemand die Hand gegeben danach dann vom Gegner?
Jeder hat mir die Hand gegeben, das ist verständlich.
Und wie hat sich das angefühlt?
Ich hätte besser gepfeifen als der echte Schiri.
Ja natürlich, es gibt ganz, ganz schlimme Schiris. Wir hatten immer einen Schiedsrichter, der hat angepfeifen, dann ist er zur Bande gegangen, da wo Schatten war und dann blieb er dort stehen und von dort aus hat er alles entschieden. Abseiß, Faul, Abstoß, Ecke, Einwurf, alles. Glaubte er einfach von da aus.
Aber immerhin, konsequente Spielwirkung.
Ja, und ich mein, das hat natürlich zu Mayhem geführt, immer auf der ihm weit entfernten Seite. Also kannst du dir vorstellen, was da los war bei Freistüßen da und so weiter. Also da hatte ich blutige Zehen danach, der Gegner aber auch ein Pferdekuss mehr. Also klar, aber ja, das ist halt unterstes Niveau. Aber man muss sich ja auch klar machen, dass ohne jetzt hier irgendjemandem in der Runde zu nahe treten zu wollen, aber ich glaube, keiner von uns war wirklich nah am Leistungssport dran.
Und dann ist es schon, oder? Jaja, also näher als wir anderen.
Ja, natürlich. Ich war auch kein schlechter Sportler und so weiter. Aber was ich damit sagen will, ist, dass man sich schon immer wieder klar machen muss, dass das eine Freizeitgestaltung ist, wenn man Fußball spielt. Man liebt diesen Sport, man liebt auch sein Team, man will auch gewinnen. Nichts ist geiler als aufzusteigen oder Meister zu werden und so weiter. Hab ich zum Glück auch mal erlebt. Das ist richtig, richtig toll. Aber es ist ja trotzdem eine Freizeitgestaltung. Wir machen uns doch alle lustig über irgendwelche Modellbauflieger hier. Wie ist das Florian nicht so tief? Dieses berühmte YouTube-Video, wo der Sohn mit Rüdiger, Rüdiger, Rüdiger, das ist natürlich sehr, sehr lustig, weil wir halt denken, ja meine Güte, ist doch nur ein Flugzeug. Aber genau so sind wir doch auf dem Fußballfeld dann auch.
Man muss doch überlegen, in Berlin, ein Kumpel von mir, der ist auch Schiri und pfeift auch relativ tief, also Kreisliga und was der an einer Grundaggressivität ausgesetzt ist, ist schon krass. Also meine Frau und ich fahren auch gern mal hin und gucken, da müssen sie zu, wie er pfeift, so ein bisschen Quarantämpfung hier in Berlin. Und das ist schon krass. Also ich meine, gut, es ist halt Kreisliga. Das heißt, die Linienrichter sind sowieso auch für einen Verein dann gestellt und sind sowieso komplett subjektiv. Aber deswegen finde ich, um da dann mal in Diskussionen anzuschließen, wenn wir immer sagen, der Profifußball ist eine Vorbildfunktion, dann müssen eigentlich auch genau diese Strafen eben auch mal über diese zwei, drei Spiele später hinausgehen. Weil das, in meinen Augen sind sie ja Vorbildfunktion. Das ist ja das, was wir konsumieren jetzt endlich, was sich dann auch widerspiegelt auf diesen Kreislegerplätzen. Und das ist schon also die Stories, die der Kumpel mir da teilweise erzählt von dieser Grundstimmung. Da wundert mich eben nicht, warum nicht so viele mehr pfeifen.
Jetzt geb ihm halt die Hand, Alex.
Ganz umsetzter Verbrechen. Alex, vorher kann ich die Sendung nicht beenden. Wenn du uns jetzt nicht versprichst, dass du das nächste Mal auf den schlechten Schiris die Hand schüttelst und ihn sagst, danke, dass wir uns möglich gemacht haben, dass wir hier spielen. Eine Stunde danach sieht man die doch nicht mehr.
Oder sind die dann noch ein paar Einzelteile? Ich bin ja Coach, ich muss ja da alles aufräumen und dies und das und dem Schiri erklären, wo er hin muss, damit er sein Geld bekommt und ihn die Schiri-Kabine aufmachen, etc. Ich hab ja immer mit denen zu tun, deswegen verstehe ich mich ja so gut mit denen. Aber manchmal wartet man ab, bis man sich wieder gut mit ihnen versteht. Sagen wir es noch so.
Es geht ja auch schon um so Kleinigkeiten. Zum Beispiel gibt es Vereine, die stellen dann auch so ein Obstkorb mal so hin oder so ein bisschen Getränke.
Aber da was gibt es zu nützlich. Ja, genau, da geht es von mir aus. Nein, Obstkorb habe ich noch nie erlebt, aber Wasser biete ich mir immer an, deswegen mögen sie mich ja auch so, aber verpfeifen sie mich immer trotzdem, das ist ja das Tragische.
Vielleicht machen sie das gar nicht mit Absicht, Alex, kann das sein?
Völlig verrückt, ne? Vielleicht hätte das gedacht.
In bestimmten Ligern bekommt man ja auch immer so Verzehrgutschein fürs Restaurant, ich kann mich mal an die Verbandsliga erinnern, da war mir alles gespannt, da war ich junger Linenrichter und da hast du so jeder 15 Euro zum Essen danach. Und dann kam nach dem Spiel, das werde ich nie vergessen, der Präsident von dem Verein in die Kabine und hat gesagt, die Gutscheine nehme ich wieder weg, esst und trinkt so viel ihr wollt, aber bitte kommt nie wieder. Und das haben wir dann gemacht, da wurde dann Vorspeise, Carpaccio, da hatten wir, unser Lehrwart war Shiri, dem war eh alles egal und dann haben wir da gegessen und ich weiß nicht, ob er jemals wieder da war, ich war da nicht noch mal, aber das war lustig.
Also Alex, du hast verschiedene Deeskalationsstufen jetzt mitbekommen, vielleicht einfach ein Big Mac Menü reinstellen und sagen, das war aber das letzte Essen von dir hier und jetzt schleicht dich. Danke, dass sie uns das Spiel ermöglicht haben.
Also in der nächsten Ligatur, wenn die Kombination wieder da ist, ich werde das nicht vergessen, frage ich mal nach, wie sich das verhalten hat.
Ja, aber wirklich. Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, die Hörerinnen und Hörer sind da auch gespannt drauf. So, auch ganz fantastisch, dass wir jetzt einfach in dieser Blitzrunde einfach so beim Tempo geblieben sind. Wollen wir einen ganz schnellen Durchgang noch machen, also von den anderen drei. Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, Daniel, ich glaube du bist dran. Hast du noch ein ganz kurzes Thema? Und dann machen wir aber, dann müssen wir hier leider die Rollenden runterlassen.
Ja, ich noch ganz kurz zum Auflust zwei MVPs. Der eine ist ja die langweilige Lösung, das ist Sam Stein, weil er irgendwie seit jedem Spieltag immer MVP ist. Er hat jetzt schon in 14 Spielen 20 Tore und 4 Vorlagen gemacht, hat das entscheidende 1-0 gegen Almere gemacht, hat seinen Marktwert, im Moment ist er bei 10 Millionen Euro. Der hat in der Saison direkt eine Freistellung gemacht und ist einfach der, der hieft Twente quasi alleine in die internationalen Plätze und der dürfte auch wie schon so oft gesagt nicht mehr allzu lange vermutlich in der RIT UC sein und diese Bereiche haben, aber ich wollte ihn trotzdem erwähnen, weil er an der Erwähnung immer wert ist. Und die andere MVP ist die spannende Lösung, das ist Christopher Peterson von Fortuna Sittard, ist Top-Torschütze von Fortuna, hat schon sieben Tore erzielt, hat jetzt auch das entscheidende 1-0 gemacht gegen Almeno und er hat eigentlich auch großen Anteil daran, dass Fortuna da ist, wo sie aktuell sind. Die sind auf Platz 8, haben 32 Punkte. Das ist für Fortuna sehr formidabel und das wäre aktuell der Playoff-Platz für die Conference League, den sie aktuell in der haben und ist mit seinen 30 Jahren auch so eine Art Lieder, auch in der Kabine. Und man kennt ihn vielleicht noch aus unserer Zeiten, wo er so vorwahrt. Und überlebt die Verantwortung, macht auch die Elfmeter und genau, das sind so meine beiden MVP's noch schnell.
Sehr, sehr schön. Mario, wen hast du noch oder was hast du noch auf dem Zettel?
Ich hab noch eine viel gute Story, die ist aber jetzt tatsächlich auch schon eine Woche her, also wem sie noch nicht irgendwie als Real durch den Algorithmus, durch einen italienischen Algorithmus bei Instagram reingespült worden ist. Jonathan Klinsmann spielt jetzt in der Serie B bei Cezena. Und da gab es letztens kurz vor Schluss einen Elfmeter gegen Cezena. Und dann hat er sich umgedreht beim Stand von 0 zu 0 und hat den Balljungen gefragt, wo der Schütze hinschießt. Und dann hat der Balljunge, der Ivan, gesagt rechts. Und dann ist Jonathan Klinsmann nach rechts gesprungen, hat den Ball gehalten. Cezena hat das Spiel sogar noch gewonnen. Danach gab es ein Trikot und eine Umarmung von Jonathan Klinsmann für Ivan. Und ja, das fand ich ganz herzerwärmend.
Sehr, sehr gut. Wahrscheinlich fängt es jetzt anders, die Gegner die Balljungen briben und bestechen und sagen, hier sag ihm rechts, dann kriegst du von mir das Trikot. Und dann wird es interessant, was Ivan macht. Aber gut. Uli, wir werden glaube ich jetzt nicht mehr über United und das neue Stadion und alles drumherum sprechen, denn das ist noch mal eine halbe Stunde. Ähnlich emotional vielleicht. Hast du noch was Kleines?
Ja, also wahrscheinlich können wir noch mal kurz nach, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das gemacht haben. Crystal Palace wäre vielleicht ein kurzes Thema, weil es relativ schnell erklärt ist. Erste acht Spiele gar nicht gewonnen. Große Kritik an Oliver Glasner haben wir, glaube ich, hier mal besprochen, wenn ich mich recht entzanne. Und jetzt aber im Verlauf der Saison sich pöa pöa gesteigert. Jetzt sind es sieben Siege in zehn Spielen und andauernde Gespräche über die Vertragsverlängerung. Also Crystal Palace hat Oliver Glasner recht klar signalisiert, dass sie mit ihm gerne weitermachen wollen. Glasner selbst soll wohl, also zumindest in den Gesprächen sein, ich weiß nicht, ob er wirklich hundertprozentig da dahinter steht, aber habe ganz oft nachgefragt, auch bei ihm, wie seine Einschätzung geht in der Saison, warum das nicht vernünftig losging. Die Einschätzung, die hat sehr sinnvoll geklungen, wenn er sie gemacht hat, nämlich fehlende Fitness. Ganz viele Spieler, die spät dazugekommen sind, zu ganz unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten noch dazu, was die Trainingssteuerung schwierig gemacht hat. Das heißt, er hat unterm Strich gesagt, die sind alle nicht fit hier, hat es auch ein bisschen ausgeweitet. Ich weiß aber nicht, wie viel davon in die Öffentlichkeit gehört und wie viel nicht. Ist jetzt auch wahrscheinlich für die Kürze irrelevant. Und das letzte Mal, als ich mit ihm gesprochen habe, hat er gesagt, jetzt habe ich die Mannschaft da, wo ich will, sonst wiehe da sie gewinnen. Es war aber noch in der Zeit, als es gar nicht gut lief für ihn. Ich sag das, man wirft ihm oder warf ihm zwischenzeitlich, das kennt man glaube ich auch noch aus Frankfurt, immer mal wieder vor, dass er schon immer die Ausreden parat hatte. Zu dem Zeitpunkt hatten sie wieder eine Negativ-Serie nicht gewonnen. Dann haben sie gesagt, jetzt gibt es keine Ausreden, auch nicht für die Truppe, die sind fit, die müssen jetzt liefern. Und seither sind sieben in zehn. Und Crystal Palace ist wieder da, wo sie letzte Saison aufgehört haben, nämlich in Schlagdistanzen für gewisse Dinge. Gibt ja ganz wilde und grude Dinge, dass theoretisch sogar ich glaube sieben Champions-Signa aus England kommen könnten und dann entsprechend glaube ich bis zu elf Europapokal teilnehmen. Da wäre jetzt ein Region.
Oh Mann ey. Ja, Entschuldigung. Also ich hatte das ja natürlich schon mal gelesen, damals schon als die Reform kam, aber der Gedanke ist einfach ein bisschen wild. Sehr schön. Ja, dann haben wir jetzt nämlich auch Oliver Glasen das Rolle dann noch ein bisschen eingeordnet. Maxence Lacroix hatten wir ja auch schon in der letzten Folge erwähnt. Ihr Vier, das hat große Freude gemacht. Das war ja fast schon psychoanalytisch, was wir hier in Teilen abgeliefert haben. Und eigentlich müssten wir fast mal die die Sendung machen, wo wir nur von unseren eigenen Fußballerlebnissen erzählen. Ich habe den Eindruck, da liegt Gold begraben und wo hast du denn, willst du das sagen? Wo ich gespielt habe? Nein, nein, nein. Ich komme ja aus Mittel beziehungsweise Unterfranken. Also der SV Unteralten Bernheim war meine erste Station. Ihr alle werdet jetzt aufhauchen wahrscheinlich. Die haben die haben damals erstmal die Jugendabteilung gründen müssen und meiner Mutter wurde nichts davon erzählt, weil die alle davon ausgegangen sind, die verbietet das bestimmt, dass ich mitspielen darf, was totaler Quatsch war. Aber naja Frauenbild auf Dörfern halt. Erste Spiel 1 zu 16 verloren, das zweite Spiel. Aber ich habe ratet, wer für die 1 gesorgt hat. Your boy. Der ganze, der ganze Sportplatz war voll, alle Eltern waren da und die haben gejubelt ohne Ende. Und ich weiß noch genau, wie mich so ein gegnerischer Spieler anguckt, als ich so zurück trabe, so langsam, natürlich auch so in die Menge grüßend Richtung. Und dann guckt er mich an und sagt so, seid ihr alle bescheuert? Weiß was 1 zu 16. Zweites Spiel dann 0 zu 36 gegen Emskirchen. Ich hab immer noch, hab immer noch einen Hass gegen Emskirchen. Wir hatten fünf verschiedene Torhüter, weil wir damals die... Weil wir hatten doch nicht, wir hatten noch nicht fix ausgemacht, wer Torhüter ist. Ich war zwischendurch auch drin. Ich hab nur zwei Gegentore kassiert. Aber der Trainer hat gesagt, nee, wir brauchen dich draußen, weil du bist der Einzige, der einen Schuss hat, der weit genug geht, dass du mal den Ball nicht gegen die Schälfte schießen kannst. Dann haben wir kurz Ruhe. Und dann, so wurde ich zum Libero. Und dann später beim SV Magdeheim. Also, do your Google Work. Jetzt könnt ihr es nachsuchen. Aber soweit ich weiß, sind die Statistiken von denen nicht so gut gepflegt. Ja. So. Tribüngespräch incoming zu unseren Fußballgeschichten. Vielen, vielen Dank euch vier. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch lieben Hörern und Hörern für euren Support. Ganz wichtig. Registriert euch bitte als Supporter erinnern, wenn ihr Daueraufträge habt. Denn die müssen geändert werden. Und in der Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Oliver Levin, bei Friedrich, bei Domaniac und bei Magda Lehner. Und ansonsten gilt natürlich, wenn ihr Feedback habt, mitmachen.rasen.de und abonniert doch bitte auch die anderen Formate. Wir sprechen über die Bundesliga der Männer, über die Bundesliga der Frauen, über das Tribüngespräch.
Ihr Assis.
Und übers Nationalteam. Und wir alle haben gerade Alex die Hand geschüttelt.
Eine Handshake zum Abschied.
Denn jetzt sind alle bösen Gedanken, die sind genau weg und zwar jetzt. Macht's gut. Tschau.
Der Rasenton lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.